Hello?
Hello, hello.
Oh, hey.
Is it my Zangief Senpai?
Oh, my god.
Is this my fellow Gief player?
Wait, are you actually playing Gief in the fighter?
Ask Ellen.
No, I fucking 5-0'd Sykkuno and mindbroken him into Zangief.
Well, that's a weird way to say showed me the light.
Yeah, he was a filthy Cammy player.
Honestly, you saved me from arthritis, you saved me from struggles, weeks of training, and my life is better now.
Why the fuck did he not do modern Cammy?
Why were you doing classic Cammy?
He tries to do it in hard mode.
That's the reason why.
Dude, dude, why even?
I'm just playing Zangief.
Wait.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
I'm gonna lock in.
I'm against a Cammy right now in ranked.
Oh, shit.
If I lose this, I go back to Cammy.
I'm also a goated Gief player.
Wait, this guy's crazy.
What the?
He's playing modern Cammy.
You could have literally played modern Cammy and then it would have been easier.
He's getting his ass kicked, dude.
He's literally on modern controls.
How are you doing moves like that?
It took me weeks to even do half of that.
That's what modern is.
You know how Gief has one button in modern?
Cammy has one button in modern.
Okay, guys, which is the one button you're pressing?
Because I'm on modern on a keyboard and I can't find the button.
Yeah, I'm on leverless.
My button's a triangle.
What about on a keyboard?
I don't fucking know what you're on.
Grab a controller.
I don't have a controller.
Grab a fucking PlayStation.
I don't have one.
It's the triangle.
Hewn!
You don't have a controller for what?
Oh, you're talking about Street Fighter.
Yeah.
We all play the same character.
Wait, really?
Yeah, but Hewn likes fighting games.
He likes to watch them though.
But, you know, maybe there's a world we get to try Street Fighter, guys.
Maybe there's a world at some point.
And hopefully we're living in the world.
Who is Sykkuno playing against tomorrow?
Who are you playing against tomorrow?
Dude, dude, this guy's fucking me.
Hold on.
Dude.
Dude, he is dialed in.
By the way, I don't think you should play Gief tomorrow because Seratina and you're playing as Seratina tomorrow and she's actively training against Gief.
Yeah, dude.
She's gonna lose to Zangief twice and never play the game again.
She's literally training just to play against Gief.
Wait, how do you train specifically against one character?
Like, how do you... Just keep playing.
against him, really.
Basically, she got one of our coaches as a modern Zangief player and she got him to coach her.
Dude, how is this...
Is that like... Which is the most simple character to play?
Is it Gief or is it like...
Zangief.
Really?
Okay, okay.
Well, if you're a beginner, it's the easiest.
Why don't you just play... What is this character called?
Blanka?
Isn't he really...
He's like... He's so-so.
I don't know.
I haven't played him, but I don't see a lot of Blanka in rank.
Oh, I was watching the... Chat, I am so sorry.
My... Guys, I wouldn't allow it for you, dude.
My volume in my ears was at max volume.
Like, literally a max volume.
Yeah, even like right now, the meta is like... Dude.
Um, I don't like...
It is.
Isn't Cammy...
I need new airdrops.
For this year?
Holy shit, dude.
Uh, we can't make it.
Selvyn might be coming, but I don't think he will be able to.
Which, hey, still a vibe, because we get through the turns quicker as well.
So we're doing it.
We're doing it, guys.
Um... Wait, wait, are we playing like, uh, Tabletop Monopoly, or the game...
or the Steam Monopoly?
Uh, Monopoly Plus?
Okay, because we might need to do Parsec for that, then.
What does that mean?
Uh, Monopoly Plus has terrible online features.
So you have to do like...
Or like Steam Controller.
Oh, wait, is this one we usually play?
Or Remote Play.
Wait, really?
Yeah, Remote Play.
Yeah, yeah, because like, Monopoly Plus, like, Ubisoft is really bad with online features, and if you use their online multiplayer, you get kicked out.
Those are the two things.
Wait, really?
Me and Psy can play this one loads, and it's always worked fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, maybe they just hate VTubers.
Because that's what happens every time.
We can give it a go, and if it goes kind of cooked, then we can just figure it out.
But yeah, I think whenever we've done it, it's usually okay.
But, I don't know, we'll just see.
We'll check it out.
I can invite you guys whenever.
Huw, you know I have you on Ubisoft, right?
Or maybe I don't, actually.
Ubisoft?
I don't know.
I don't think so, but holy frick, this thing has taken like 50 years to load.
Also, the intro music, when you load in it, is so loud, just it blew off my eardrums, also my chats.
It was so freaking loud.
Um...
Yeah, I always mute every Steam game because it's so loud.
Yeah, holy Christ.
It was, uh, that was a whole thing.
Um, whenever me and Psy play Monopoly, it gets kind of hectic.
I'm gonna give you the pre-warning.
We kind of just grief each other repeatedly.
Um...
That's basically Monopoly, then.
That's basically Monopoly.
You don't want the other to win.
Oh, God.
Don't you get it?
I can't believe we won in Twitch Rivals, man.
We got the squad!
That was so RNG.
That's so...
You guys all got, like, Alien.
Alien, dude.
Oh, God.
That RNG was fucking crazy.
The fact that we were lost as well up until then is crazy.
Like, that's insane, right?
Yeah.
Um, let me do this.
Hard bit.
Where's my Ubisoft password?
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
I do the same thing.
Every time I play this game, I always forget I have to log in.
Every single time.
It's stupid that you have to log in via Ubisoft to play a Steam game.
Yeah.
Dude, that's... I'm a Zangief main.
I just... I destroyed that guy so badly.
You destroyed a modern Cammy that's actually...
These Cammy players think they can play the game and I just push one button.
It's so funny.
Alright, I'm opening up about Monopoly.
I forgot my password.
Yeah, I don't remember.
Guys!
Here, fine.
I'm gonna hit the recover password and I'm gonna enter every single email address that I think I'm gonna be using.
Um...
Chat, would you like a good Monopoly song?
I don't know what a good Monopoly song is.
You know, we're gonna go with Roller of Music.
Chat, do we want Monopoly music or do we want... do we want...
our music?
I think maybe we go with our music.
I think it's more of a vibe than the Monopoly soundtrack.
Brazil!
Chat, if he is able to show up we can obviously write it back or do whatever.
I don't know whether he's gonna be... if he's able to or not, but, um...
I also don't wanna, uh, spam him.
So, we'll... if so, it's available.
Dope.
If not, it's also okay.
You know?
As we will rock you, that's gonna be the vibe, dude.
Oh my god, chat.
You know what song I've been loving recently, dude?
Yes, chat.
Last night, we let the liquor talk.
We let the liquor talk.
Members in it's in it's...
Dude, dude, dude.
Bro, this is a banger, dude.
Dude, this song goes crazed.
Dude, this song goes... You mean, ew.
Are you joking?
Bro, this song goes crazy, bro.
It goes crazy.
Who is that?
Who is what?
Alright, I'm ready.
Send out the invite.
Let me invite.
Inviting.
Come on.
What happened to your old name?
Oh, I changed it because I did a sponsor with Tina and I didn't think having big dong Allen was probably a Yeah, you can change your name?
Yeah, you can change your name.
That's a very good reason to change it, yeah.
Wait, he's a controversial singer?
Wait, is he?
Oh, I didn't know that.
If he is, in which case...
Dude, now that you've converted me to Zangief, like, I love the game now.
It's actually fun.
Yeah, it's more fun, right?
Playing as Zangief?
Yeah.
I'm enjoying it.
The funny thing is I just went against another Cammy who had better combos than I had.
And I just destroyed him with one button.
I just kept pushing one button and they lost.
Yeah, because you don't have to try as much.
Nice.
It's just... Zangief is literally just reactions.
You can just play off of reactions and not... But I have terrible reactions.
He's so satisfying to play.
You know, when you hit the ground it goes crazy.
Yeah, when you hit it, it's like insane.
I just can't believe it took me this long to realize.
It just took me this long.
No, you should carry on with Cammy.
No, I want to win.
I like winning.
I want to be last.
You know how hard I have to try to wait.
Wait, Lili.
Huh?
Wait, are you fighting in...
Wait, is this Lili as in Lili Pichu?
Lili?
Wait a minute.
No, no, no.
It can't be Lili Pichu, can it?
Is it?
I mean, I'm pulling it up.
By the way, if it is Lili... Yeah, yeah, it is her.
Dude, I think it's actually her.
You randomly matched?
Lili is the worst counter match.
Wait, she knows the tech, bro?
Lili is the worst counter matchup for Zangief, by the way.
She's like the hardest to play against.
Oh, dude.
Who does Lili play?
No, my new main.
Lili is playing Lili and because Justin Wan told us, told me that this character is like the pure counter match of Zangief.
Wait, really?
Oh, shit.
Because she can hit you from afar, basically.
Dude, one more of those grabs, I still win, though.
Yeah, you still have to hit that grab.
He's gotta hit it.
Oh, dude.
If he's available, yeah.
If not, it's also completely okay.
By the way, chat, I know right now...
Just to let you guys know, Pico part 2 on Thursday, so far confirmed, is me, Selbit, Nicewig, and Sykuno.
I've asked...
I've asked a bunch of people, so we're gonna see the full squad, but so far, we got half the lobby.
But Selbit's gonna be playing on Thursday for that as well, so that's gonna be dope as hell.
It's gonna be awesome, bro.
It's gonna be awesome.
Because it's a plus.
So, you know how she does that twisty thing?
You have to make sure she does that.
I'm just playing again.
I keep pushing my counter button instead of my, uh...
Triangle?
Do you guys have any Ubisoft names?
So I can add you guys?
Oh, I already have you added, man.
I don't have...
One button combo?
I think it has to be Ubisoft.
Which is the problem.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, how do I add you on Ubisoft?
So basically you press...
The club?
Okay, I found it.
What's your name, Elm?
Barnacle Bing.
Barnacle...
Hey, Ubisoft Club.
Okay.
Where's mine?
Oh, mine's Real Female Doki.
Real...
Female...
Doki.
Okay, I added you.
There you go.
There's one, and then friend request done.
Oh, I got it.
Boom!
And then I'll make a new lobby.
Cause I'm just gonna time out.
Um...
He's getting his ass kicked right now.
Create a game.
Uh...
Private...
Private, private, private, private, private.
Uh...
Living board.
I think if Sykuna wins his first match, he plays against Lily's team.
Oh, is it?
Oh wait, do you guys...
Do you have like squads?
Is that how it works?
Yeah, yeah, we have a tournament tomorrow.
We have like the final tournament date tomorrow.
Oh...
That's why he's...
That's why he's fucking practicing.
Oh...
Like a week ago, maybe like a week and a half ago.
First time he played Street Fighter, I was...
Is it Dao Sim or something like that?
I beat his ass for an hour, and then I think he got so scarred for it because that's never happened in any game.
And then he just came back and now just kicks my ass every time.
It's so annoying.
Do you play Tekken, Doki?
Yeah, I play Tekken.
I did the Tekken tournament.
Oh shit, nice.
Yeah, we've been playing Tekken.
But even like that, I'm like...
I didn't realize, because I just started playing ranked on that, but I play Jhin.
Pretty much only play Jhin.
And...
When you're like low rank, how you can just spam one move and you just win.
Oh, that is so true.
It's just a knowledge check.
Well, I would low kick and just...
In the super low ranks, people just don't check low kicks.
So I would just do up, low, low, up, up, low, low, low, low, up, low, and just do that repeatedly.
I think that's just fighting games.
People just don't block lows.
No, they just don't.
I think it's because it doesn't look...
Honestly, I think it's because the move also just doesn't look cool.
It's just like a boring kick, right?
But they always like...
Especially in Tekken, they hit.
Low kicks actually do damage if you hit them a lot.
Yeah, yeah, I agree, yeah.
I abuse a lot of the low kicks.
Because people just don't block it.
I think if I learned one other move, I actually will be unbeatable.
All I do is push the one button grab and the DI, and that's all I've done.
See, if you hit your DI, just press triangle.
Yeah, that's all I do.
Yeah, that's like the best part.
You should press OD triangle.
Overdrive triangle.
Overdrive triangle gives you more damage.
I mean, I've done that with TOS.
It works.
Is Doki...
Is she Doki?
Is she good at fighting games?
From the way she talks, I'm assuming she is.
She's cracked.
Dude, I want to watch...
You know what's crazy?
The first time I ever met Doki, or even actually become familiar with her, was during the Twitch Rivals.
was during the Twitch Rivals.
But I immediately loved her energy.
By the moment I joined and she just had this crazy, crazy good energy, I was like, I want to play with her.
I love people with energy.
The moment she started talking, I was like, I love her.
She has good fucking energy and she's funny.
I was like, I want to invite her to shit.
She's fun.
I think I'm going to invite her to a bunch of shit.
She's great.
I really like her.
She's really, really cool.
Check.
Oh yeah, the back rolling grab.
Yep, I got that one.
It's just mostly all grabs.
And then like, forward circle.
Dude, she's great.
Honestly, she's great.
For real, for real.
She's awesome.
She's really, really cool.
I said before guys, I like...
I like...
I like it when people come in with just like fucking energy.
When we did the Twitch Rivals thing and she just starts roasting me because some of the shit...
Bear in mind, we haven't really even interacted at that point.
We just go in and I'm just like being an idiot.
She just roasts me for it.
I was like, I like that.
Because she's like coming at me with just like insult after insult after insult after insult.
And I'm like, yeah, I fuck with that.
That's like...
I like people I can bounce off.
That's why I'm definitely going to invite her to more shit.
She's funny as fuck, dude.
Oh, we've been here.
We're waiting for you, motherfucker.
I told you, motherfucker.
I literally told you three times.
I told you three times.
I'm angry at you.
I was enjoying the Zangief.
It's just so good.
I genuinely think if I spend more than 15 seconds...
So I went into the combo trial, literally spent 15 seconds to learn that pushing triangle does a move and then I just went straight into games after that.
I've just been winning.
Dude, I took a round off Lillian, almost beat her.
She's been laughing against Zangief for like a very long time.
I had 15 seconds of practice.
Yeah, and Lillian is like the counter pick to Zangief too, so that's why.
Did you get the invite, bro?
Sorry?
You got like 15 seconds.
Wait, he's in the game?
I don't see him.
No, he's in the lot, like the main menu.
Let me remake it.
It was just going to time out.
Let me make her...
I'm a Zangief main now.
He's a Zangief main now.
And Lillian is the hardest matchup and I almost beat her with only 15 seconds of practice, only knowing one singular button.
That's crazy.
That's so fucked.
She's been laughing against Zangief for like several hours every day.
Why train for hours when you can push one button after 15 seconds?
Dude, if I train for 15 more minutes it's a GG.
Oh god.
What do I want to be?
I'm going to be this thing.
I'm being this thing.
I'm a dog.
Doki, we do like fighting game lobbies.
You should join.
I didn't know you were like an OG of the Tekken Street Fighter.
Oh, I am not.
I literally learned fighting games because of the Seijan slam shit that Tycoon and I are invited to.
And now you're hooked.
I invite you by the way, Huynh.
I mean, I like it more now that I'm a Zangief main.
It's a lot more fun now.
Before I'm pushing like a hundred buttons to do no damage.
Now, I walk at them.
Your character is all about being fast and trying to do as many attacks as possible.
And then I push one button and I equal your attack.
Your 20 attacks.
I have to do some crazy combo that I practiced for like a week for to do less damage than one button.
Yeah, but it looks cool though.
It looks cool though, man.
You know, maybe go for the Star Wars.
Let me be the Zangief.
Give me the Zangief.
This is the first time I felt like I've been having fun playing Street Fighter.
I ain't gonna lie.
It was a struggle till then.
And now I'm like, yeah, this is kind of fun.
There's Dao Sim, bro.
Dao Sim main with his stretchy legs.
That guy went crazy, bro.
Yeah, those were the old days, but now I'm a Zangief-er.
I'm a Zangief-er, man.
Okay, here we go, guys.
Time for some Monopoly.
Yippee!
Roll!
Give me something big.
Big juicer.
Okay, okay.
Nothing too shabby.
Nothing too shabby there.
It's your turn.
Alright, my turn.
Roll!
Nothing too shabby.
Oh!
At least we know who's gonna be last.
Dokia!
You're messed up!
Is it my turn?
Eleven?
Yeah, she got freaking eleven.
Yeah, you can get ten or twelve.
Oh!
Eight, I feel like, isn't even that bad.
No, it's not.
Just everyone's been rolling high.
I'm gonna think I'm rolling a two here.
Nah, I hear you and I believe in you.
I believe in you.
I'm feeling it.
No way.
I'm last.
It's all over for me.
It's all over.
What?
No way!
Nine?
I'm last.
None of us even rolled low.
It's crazy.
Dokia, I've been told that apparently last time you played Monopoly, you just, in capital letters, destroyed everybody.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
She's a pro.
She's a damn pro.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
She got the rip.
What do I get?
What is that?
Ooh!
A blue.
Hell yeah, I'm gonna purchase that.
Oh, God.
Okay, okay.
As long as I get a couple of reds along the way, I'll be fine.
A couple of reds along the way.
Hey, I'm an orange.
Well, wait.
But what if I get orange?
You wanna be willing to trade with me, man?
Okay.
Yeah, I'll trade for it.
I don't think me and you have ever done a successful trade before, by the way.
I think we've just inted each other the whole time.
Since we're both geef players, we should work together.
Oh, yeah, for sure.
And make sure Ellen loses.
But I'm also a geef player!
He's a fake geef player.
No, no, he's a fake geef player.
He doesn't know the special grab button.
Yeah, he doesn't understand.
He doesn't know the triangle button.
He's a keyboard geef player.
He's pushing buttons instead of triangle.
I wanna form an alliance with you.
Me and you.
An alliance?
Hey, you wanna work with Sykuna and I?
Dude!
Yeah, I'm down.
You're fake.
That's crazy.
Oh, thanks for your Hey, Doki.
Hey, Doki.
Do you wanna form an alliance with me and Sykuna?
No.
Sykuna, do you want Ellen to lose?
I mean...
Yeah, but I want him to think he has a chance to win.
What the f- It's not fun if they know they're gonna lose.
That's what he does on Street Fighter.
What he'll do on Street Fighter is he'll give me a round and then fucking annihilate me for like three games after.
He does it every time.
He's gotta play Geese, man.
Oh, seven.
That puts me on Community, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
Maybe you get to go to Broadway.
But now you've got no properties, man.
Zero.
No!
I'm going back to saying Geese.
Oh, man.
Give me my shmoney.
Give me my shmoney, baby.
Okay.
Nice.
Ooh, where do I go here?
Classic six.
One of the pinks, maybe?
Wait, you're just collecting properties, bro.
Oh, hey!
I got pink!
You're just collecting these properties.
This is BS.
I'm just gonna collect the properties.
I hope you guys get six as well.
Huynh, I hope you get six.
I thought that was part of your allies.
Huynh, you see that?
At the first moment of weakness, she wants to attack you.
I know mine.
This is taxes.
I'm just encouraging her to pay taxes.
Oh, wow.
Did you get $100?
In the last place, I've been giving my money away.
I mean, what else could go wrong for me?
4Corp, you're such a troll.
Hey, technically, you...
Technically, I know you have zero property, but at least you're not the most poor.
Who is the most...
Oh, hey, thanks for...
Honestly, I'm here to funnel her.
Dude, how is Doki winning in every single game?
She's my offshore bank account.
It's like you're gonna funnel me.
It's like you're gonna funnel me, brother.
They're filming an alliance.
The boys gotta stick together here, brother.
This doesn't land me on you.
Does it?
Is this the railroad or is this I lose money?
Oh, it's the railroad.
I think I'll buy this one.
Okay.
Do it.
It's a train station.
Railroads are not...
Are they good?
They're good if you have all of them.
Because if you have all of them, then it's like...
Because that's how I won Monopoly.
Wait, you like played this on the regular?
No, because the last time I played Monopoly, I got all the railroads just by traveling around.
She's a damn pro.
Everybody just kept landing on it.
That's how you win in Monopoly.
It's such a big disadvantage.
I can't buy any of these things.
Please, for the love of God, just give me a property.
I need one.
If you get the railroad, you're gonna give it to me, right?
Oh yeah, 100%.
You?
My guy?
Of course.
Look at that.
What does Ellen get in return?
He gets the other thing.
What's the other thing?
Yeah, what's the other thing?
What was it called?
What color did you like again?
Blue.
I like dark blue, actually.
There's no way I can get a dark blue.
Why not?
You give me the dark blue, I'll give you the railway station.
I'll tell you what.
You give me the railroad now, so I can start making money.
And I'll give you the dark blue when I get it.
Dude, you're a liar.
You're not gonna give it to me.
You won't.
I'm good on my word.
You always betray me.
What do you mean?
I'll give it to you if I land on it.
Then I'll give it to you.
It's gonna be different, Ellen.
Today's the one day he's gonna work with me.
I'm gonna make the money back, bro.
You give me this thing.
I'm gonna make the money back and pay you back.
After playing Risk with this guy for about six months straight every day, let me tell you, he doesn't pay it back.
He wants it now.
I put that deal up, bro.
I put that deal up, okay?
I put up that deal.
Here, I give you one dollar.
No, no, no, bitch.
I want two hundred bucks.
I want two hundred bucks as a sign of good faith.
You're not gonna give it to me.
You won't give it to me.
Okay, fine.
I'll give you two hundred to break it even.
And then when I give you the blue one, you give me the two hundred back.
Yeah, it's a loan.
That's fine.
We call it a loan, and when I get the blue one and give it to you, you pay me back.
We both win.
You give me this railroad, I make the money back with the railroad.
One more condition.
You say that I'm a better geith than you.
What?
I thought you didn't want me to be a liar, man.
You dickhead.
I reject that deal after you said that.
That's how you know I'm honest, dude.
That was a test.
That was a test to see if I was honest, and I passed.
That was a test to see if I was honest, and I think I passed that.
Just saying.
And I'm gonna make the money back with this railroad.
I'm telling you, man.
You give me this loan now, I double my money instantly, and then bam.
Railroad shit.
That was a huge test.
Orange.
No, I want the orange.
I don't want the blue.
Give me the orange.
No, no.
You.
You said blue only.
That is insane.
Deal's locked in.
I told you not to accept the deal, LM.
I told you.
But you don't even have the dollar blue yet.
You don't even have it.
If I did though, you know.
What is this?
Oh, another orange.
Let's go.
Dude, Doki is just getting everything.
Doki is getting everything.
If she gets my railroad, it's gonna be over.
If she gets my dollar blue, then Sykuno's gonna go, oh, that's a dollar blue, I owe you.
I know what he's gonna do.
I know what this guy's gonna do.
I think I just need to copy Doki in every single game.
Here we go.
Please.
Wait.
There's no way I go to jail.
I'm moving up Apex after this, man.
You're going to jail?
Oh.
Bro.
That's a bad thing.
He forgot to bring his cash.
Isn't that like super bad right now?
I have nothing.
Nothing.
Yeah, but you could have bought stuff.
Have you been tax evading her?
Maybe.
Maybe a little, but you know, it's just a smidge.
Have you done your taxes?
No.
We got live on stream.
Oh, she got me in squatting.
Waterworks.
Dude, is this one even worth buying?
I'm going to just buy it just for fun.
I knew it was worth it.
Honestly, I feel like, you know, they're kind of cheap as well.
Better than nothing, I guess.
Okay, I need to land an orange.
Wait, if I come back and I steal one, this could still be fine.
This could still be fine.
Dude, wait.
I don't know.
Is that Railway?
No shot.
Is that another Railway?
Oh, it's yellow.
Oh, it's not unknown yellow too.
No way.
I'm going to sell this yellow for the top, top dollar.
What do you want to do?
This is what he does.
I feel like each of us owns at least one color.
Well, yeah, that's true.
Yeah, each of us owns one of the colors.
I want to point out, by the way, he said well because he's looked at mine and gone, his one's pathetic.
That's why he went well.
That's the...
Tell me that isn't true.
You're just paranoid.
See?
He's paranoid.
What did he do to you?
Everything.
Why are you so paranoid?
Tell him he's paranoid.
I know him.
Tell him how he is.
Tell him.
It's like...
Get me out of here.
It's like somebody's going to die and then you're like, I bet it's like who knows.
I bet he's the one that did it.
Yeah, see?
It's true.
Please.
Did you pay $50 to get out?
Yes, I did.
I won this orange.
Why did you pay $50?
Because I won the orange.
Look.
Free orange.
I'm losing my fucking mind.
You have to pay the price.
Helping out a friend.
I thought you guys were comrades.
Let's not forget that I gave you $200.
So technically, you're just giving me back the $200.
But you're going to give me that dollar.
You're going to jail.
Dude, that's prison though, isn't it?
But you go to jail.
You still get a roll again.
I also evaded some taxes.
Oh, hewn.
It was a bad argument.
Oh, I guess not.
Dude, if I go to jail here, I'm going to mold.
I'm free.
Oh, you're free.
Wait a minute.
This is the green one I think you just bought.
Did I just buy that?
Oh, my God.
Oh, hey, thanks.
Thanks for paying my mortgage.
Big money.
Your turn starts now.
Yeah, you can't.
You can't.
Dude, please.
Yes.
Wait a minute.
No, wait.
No, Dougie.
No, no, no, wait, wait, wait.
There is a God in this world.
Oh, my God.
Thank Christ.
I almost got it.
Dude, I was about to go scorched earth.
I hope you also get taxed.
I swear to God.
Wait, why?
I'm poor.
I'm in last place right now.
Dude, I was about to go scorched earth.
What happened to Zangiefers?
Why don't Zangiefers stick together?
Yeah, we're sticking together.
We both have to pay our taxes together.
You already paid enough for the rolls of us.
Wait, no.
Did you say you want to follow my footsteps?
I'm probably... Wait, yes.
Except for that tax thing.
Please, please.
Dude, I'm going to fucking...
I'm actually going to mold.
This is perfect.
What do you mean?
This is good for you.
Oh, it's free parking.
This is so good for you.
No, no, no.
I want the orange.
I want the orange now.
You give me the orange and I give you the dark blue.
I changed my mind.
No, it's okay.
Let's go back on the deal.
You can't just change your mind.
It's a signed contract.
Do I keep paying money to people?
Bro.
Dude, Ellen, we had a deal already.
Yeah, you can't just back out on the deal.
I get the oranges, you get the blue.
No, that wasn't the deal.
You said you wanted the railway stations.
Yeah, railways and oranges.
That isn't what you said.
No, I agree.
I'm pretty sure you said that.
You said orange and railroads.
I've always said the oranges are my thing.
They're my thing, man.
No, he definitely said that.
I remember.
Donkey, you're my alliance.
Remember that?
Remember?
Remember we formed that bond?
I don't remember that.
You're a keyboard thief.
I don't know what that is.
God, dude.
Holy...
Am I going to buy this one?
They're being mean to me.
Dude, I'm auctioning this.
What are they being mean to you?
I don't know.
I think it's because it's deserved.
You know it's deserved at this point, I think.
I think you have like...
You know how in games you have a hidden trait on birth?
Yours is like you taunt people and then they...
They just have to make fun of you.
Oh, I think you got a bid, June.
You got a bid.
Either withdraw or bid for a brown.
Uh...
I mean, the price is $22 right now.
Which means you can buy it and mortgage it back for $30.
You literally can't lose money at this point.
Yeah, that's true.
I'm going to bid a dollar over.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I'll bid a dollar.
Not all just bid a dollar.
If you bid $100, they won't grab it.
Why would you?
$100?
You're going to pay $135 for this garbage?
No, no, I'm out.
We're in this garbage.
$135 for...
That's like a shit.
No way.
You bought like a little tent.
I'm backing out of this.
Let me tell you that one.
You never know how many times you guys might land on this thing.
True, true.
What if it wins the game?
You might regret it.
A hotel only is $250.
A little hotel.
That $250 is going to go a long way.
Oh, my God.
A long way.
A hotel on it, which is...
Your time has come.
I'm usually at $200.
Do I land on it?
Wait, you don't land on the other ground.
There's no shot.
Dude, that would have been so troll, dude.
That would have been so troll.
I can't believe I actually landed.
Oh, yay!
I got $10!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Nice, nice.
That's free money right there.
Give me something good.
Oh, that's big.
That's big.
Please.
Wait, that lands you on...
Yeah, that's perfect.
You get a blue.
Oh, you got the blue!
I told you you would get a dark blue.
No, not squares, you dick.
You got the blue.
No, you give me the other blue.
So help me, Syke.
How am I going to get the other blue?
You already got one blue.
I'll tell you what.
You give me the orange and I promise you...
No, I don't give you that until you give me the blue.
What do you mean no?
We'll do a fair trade.
If I get the orange now, I can start making money with it.
Farming me.
This ain't risk, bro.
We're not doing that all over again.
What do you mean?
You're not farming me for troops.
You're not farming me for troops again.
It's as simple as that.
Oh, wait.
You got both of them.
And you got the waterworks as well, right?
Dude, that's an auction.
Dude, I'm auctioning this one, dude.
Oh, okay.
I'll do a hundred off the bat.
Because I know this one's worth a lot.
Alright, I'll get one dollar in there.
Huun, by the way, I think with those brands, if you get hotels, they're not actually that expensive to get a fully max...
I think the houses are super cheap.
So you can juice them up pretty early if someone lands on them.
Yeah, well, Suits, you need both.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I did not realize that was me.
You know what?
I'm good.
Oh, he just backed out immediately.
Not even a dollar.
I'm good, you know what I mean?
I could put a hundred dollars.
I'll put another ten bucks.
I'll put one dollar in here.
If you put a hundred, Sykuna's gonna drop out.
Dude, he won't.
I'll drop out for fifty.
No way, you go 2.32 on that?
Were you made of money?
Jesus.
Huun's in jail.
Huun's got the trust fund money.
She's got the trust fund, guys.
That's all.
I think she's gonna back down off of this bet.
You bid?
She's backing down, bro.
She's scared.
Even a hundred dollars, Sykuna will drop out.
Doki, shut up.
Actually, I'm going to make...
Dude, if we let her have this, she's gonna get like the double bonus.
Right?
Yeah, she gets ten times.
It's more than double.
Well, Sykuna, I'm just letting you know I'm gonna put a hundred in if you don't stop.
You think I'm afraid?
Oh, dude, I misclicked.
He's trying to end you.
That's insane.
No, I was definitely still going.
That is actually insane.
Oh, wait, you're actually...
Oh my god.
Dude, that's so troll.
Dude, Doki, you're insane.
You're insane for this.
She has the other one.
She has the water.
It is a big benefit.
Me and Doki are just gonna put one dollar.
One dollar in.
What the fuck?
Someone's gotta back down.
Dude, what is happening?
Dude, one of you should just put a hundred.
What's the cap out?
I feel like it's not worth it after like three hundred something bucks, right?
Like, there's no way it's worth it.
I don't know.
I think it's worth...
I think it's worth a lot.
I'd say like mathematically...
At least like three hundred or so.
She'll fall for you.
She's still going.
There's actually no way.
Dude, who's just hitting enter?
Honestly, I'm just hitting enter.
She's just hitting enter.
Doki, hit a hundred.
Hit a hundred.
See if she's spamming enter.
Hit a hundred, Doki.
She's button mashing.
She might be a bit of a street fighter.
She's mashing.
You just gotta get her with a...
Oh, she wasn't mashing.
She wasn't mashing.
She's strategic now.
Dude, this is actually a war.
That's double.
306 is crazy.
I think it's still kind of worth because now she has both.
Yeah, but then she had to fight for it.
I'm fine with that.
God diggity dang, bro.
God diggity dang.
I forgot I auctioned that.
Alright, Elim listen.
Dude, no, bro.
No.
I'll give you the yellow.
I don't need the yellow!
But the yellow is worth more money!
Okay, how about if I get the orange one on the next roll, then we trade for the yellow.
And if you land on it, and I'll pay you back double.
Do you really believe him?
I don't believe a single word this guy says.
If I lie to you about this, then you never will trust me again.
And you know I wouldn't do that.
Do you like your investment over there?
It's going to be better for both of us.
No, it's going to be better for you, because then you're going to get...
Then I'm going to land the railway stations, you're going to have all the orders, then you're going to be like, then you're going to stop following me whenever I get down that lane again.
No dude, I'll never charge you, I'll never charge you.
You can't, you don't have an option.
You're not, what do you mean?
Just don't pay, just don't pay.
Just trade me before and I'll pay you back double.
I'll pay you back double, dude.
Wait a second.
I use the money to make some money.
Do an IOU right now.
I've been trying to do an I...
I use the money to make some money, everybody wins.
I've been trying to do an IOU.
Even better, Ellum, you don't even have to lift a finger.
Pay me out.
Yeah, I'll manage all of it, I'll buy the houses, I'll do everything.
Pay me out, pay me out.
All you gotta do is regret not giving me that orange sooner, because I'm going to make us both so much money with it.
So you're saying you'll give me 50% of your earnings from when you land on that?
I'll tell you what, I'll tell you what, I'll cut you an even better deal.
I give you 100% of my earnings until you're paid back, and then 50% in perpetuity in the future.
Wait, what about the interest rates?
What's the interest rate?
Yeah, yeah.
50% of future profits?
Future profit, man, you're getting 50%...
That's not an interest rate, that's just a... that's a royalty fee.
Dude, that's better than interest, that's better than interest.
Yeah, but you have to include interest and royalty in the contract.
50% is insane already, that's insane!
You're getting 50% and you don't have to do anything.
I also want a guarantee, so I need an upfront payment of 400 bucks just in case.
400, okay, if I get the third one, it's a deal.
If I get the third one, it's a deal.
Okay, bye.
400 is kind of almost all my money.
400 bucks?
Yeah, dude, 400 bucks is almost all my money.
And the 50% and the 50% and the dark blue and we're good.
And the dark blue if I land on it.
But if someone else lands on it, I want you to try and you need a pitch as to why I should get it.
I want you to be my lawyer, okay?
You gotta be my lawyer.
I mean, I'll try, but I can tell you it's probably... they ain't gonna give it to me.
I mean, you really set the strategy out loud, so, but I'll damn it.
Wait!
No!
You!
Oh my god, big money, big money.
Dude, you got the pinks.
Enjoy that dokey, you big nerd.
You hand me those oranges, you get the pinks, we take over this town.
We take over this town.
It's a win.
Ooh, okay, okay.
That's seven.
Where am I?
That's it, that's perfect.
Why do I keep landing on his face?
Perfect, perfect.
I needed that money.
See, LMR, investment's paying off for you.
No problem.
Very good.
That wouldn't have been possible without you.
Hey, we're business partners now, you know?
Right?
Yeah, now give me that orange and we're chillin'.
Number five on my own railroad.
I think you're gonna backstab each other the moment they are going to backstab you.
That's the other thing.
We have the strongest, I mean, it's just not gonna happen.
No, we have a strong bond, we have a strong bond, we know, we know now.
It's not even my own property.
A classic yellow, a classic yellow, let's go.
We need somebody to get him a monopoly.
Nobody has a monopoly.
Oh, wait, I mean, only Huynh has a monopoly.
Dude, give me that orange.
I think all three yellow.
Give me the other orange.
Wait a second.
Wait.
All three...
No.
That's a six, that's communal.
There's one more yellow.
No.
There's not even any trade.
Oh, come on, dude.
Oh, wow.
Why, bro?
That's such...
We have to pay taxes.
We have to pay school fees.
You're just losing money from just the community.
No.
Wait, this is bad.
This is bad.
Why?
Where is that?
This is bad.
Dude.
Sykkuno.
I got yellow.
You said yellow.
And you said, I don't need that.
That's not how it sounds.
I don't need that.
I tried my best.
I tried my best to do the sound.
I don't need that.
I couldn't...
But he definitely said that.
I offered you the yellow.
I was like, I'll give you the yellow.
Dude.
I'll have the yellow.
Nobody wants it.
I'll take the yellow.
Well, I'll take the yellow.
I'll take the orange yellow.
For the orange.
No, No, but for the blue.
For the blue, brethren.
For the blue.
Of course.
And the 400 bucks up, guarantor.
Roll me a 10, roll me a 10 if there's...
Oh, an 11.
Wait a minute.
Wait a second, wait a second.
Dude, Ellum has this one.
Oh no, it's the card.
Yes!
$50!
Let's go!
I think that Kuno has been like earning like $200 in this one.
This feels like when I switched to modern Zangief instead of classic Zangief.
Where's that?
Oh, does anyone... what is that?
Wait, that's free.
Whatever it is, it's free.
What is that?
Oh, it's because it's a chance being a thing.
Alright, what is that?
Oh, hey!
Oh, wow!
Hey, Doki!
Doki!
Wow!
So, Doki!
What's the deal here?
Doki, my good friend Doki, you know...
Give me your blue.
Me and you, we go way back.
Give me your blue!
Oh, so you're ditching your alliance?
You're not even loyal.
You're already ditching your alliance with Sykkuno.
What do you mean?
No, no, no.
Because if you give me the dark blue, then I'll give him the orange.
So really, you're only screwing Sykkuno over if you don't give it to me.
Oh, so you are screwing him over.
I mean, I'll take the orange, I mean...
No, wait a second.
If I land on Mayfair now, I'm going to go scorch your earth and just...
How did we all land on Mayfair?
We're just Trafalgar Square.
We're not huge, dude.
You say Illinois?
I'm in Trafalgar Square.
Am I seeing a different game team?
Oh, nobody has that.
The reds are on the board if anyone wants to make a crazy trade for it.
Here we go, please.
Give me something good.
Wait.
Wait a second.
Is that jail?
It's jail.
Oh, for frick's sake, dude.
To be honest, at least you passed Go and got $200.
Honestly, being in jail is safe right now because almost every property is bought now.
Guys, I'm open for trades.
I'm open for trades.
Let me tell you that, okay?
We got to figure out some kind of trades to go over here.
Well, actually, the only ones available are like...
Not yellow.
Red?
Red and blue are the only available ones.
Like, of all owned properties.
You get $150, dude?
$150?
Jesus.
God damn.
Give me a nine.
Looking for a nine here.
That's not a nine.
Seven.
Where's that gonna land you?
Who owns that?
Oh, that's nothing.
No, no.
It's the...
Oh, it's the other brown.
Oh, my God.
That was Hewn's monopoly.
That's what it was.
I buy this and leverage it against Hewn with an auction.
What?
$100.
No way.
You know what?
Hewn needs this.
She'll have the first monopoly in the game if she gets this.
$10.
She'll literally be the only person who can upgrade her properties.
I'm doing this mainly because I just wanna see what Hewn does.
Is he gonna put in $100?
I feel like it's gotta be... Oh, dude!
But guys, it's...
We have to stop her because if she buys this and we can't make a deal, she's the only person who can upgrade houses.
Like, it's too powerful to let her have... I'm bidding $1.
I'm bidding $1.
If you really wanna stop her, just bid $100.
Dude, $450 with a hotel?
She's gonna be cooking us.
If you really wanna stop her, just bid $100.
Yeah, just bid $100 if you wanna stop me.
Yeah, so bid $100.
Someone's gonna...
You have a lot of money.
Divide it by 10.
Yeah, there it is.
There it is.
I'm gonna bid $100.
Hit $100.
I'm bidding $100 right now.
There it is.
Dude, how high is she gonna go?
Dude, how valuable do you want this?
Just do it.
Do $100 here.
You're not gonna do it.
How valuable do you want this soon?
Okay, according to my estimates, I'd say the most value is like $450, cause then someone would only need to land on it once for her to get paid back, right?
Cause you get $450 with a hotel.
So there's no way she pays more than $450 for it.
Unless, like, she thinks that... She's grayed out cause she voted out of the bid, basically.
I feel like math-matically...
What do you mean?
Dude.
Oh, man.
It's up to you, man.
You gotta stop her.
Bid $100.
Why is it Ellen's job?
Ellen bid $100.
I'll give you the yellow.
I'll give you the yellow, bro.
You'll give me the yellow?
Yeah, I'll give you the yellow.
For the orange.
Wait.
Oh, man.
Dude, I don't know if I...
I'm getting kinda... I'll do $100.
And see what she does.
Wow.
You didn't do another $100.
Well, I feel like maximum mathematical value is still higher than this.
Because she'll be the only... She'll actually have the monopoly.
And nobody else will.
That's crazy.
Fuck that, dude.
Dude, she actually... She's crazy.
She's crazy, man.
Oh, my God, dude.
Why are you getting mad at me?
You're the one who backed out first.
You made me lose hope.
Now she has a monopoly.
We're gonna lose the game.
That's down to you, bro.
That's down to you.
You're an idiot.
You're a bumbling idiot.
Dude, you backed out and made me lose confidence.
There's actually no way they gave up.
Why did you give up?
Because you gave up first.
Communicate with me, bro.
Communicate with me.
You're the worst Keefer I've ever seen.
...on this bomb and we're done.
We're done.
This game's gonna be over quick.
We're gonna be dead.
We're just gonna be dead.
I thought we had an unspoken bond, you idiot.
Dude, she's got a monopoly.
It's actually, we're in trouble now.
And now she's gonna sue all the houses and none of us is gonna be able to monopolize any of our properties because Sykkuno's an idiot.
Actually, you backed out first.
Yeah, and I wouldn't have...
What are you, a fucking pirate?
What the hell does that even mean?
Oh wait, this is my turn.
Dude, I keep doing these postions and since Hewn won, I was like, oh, it must be her turn.
No, no, Sivin.
Is this the taxi?
I've known taxis before.
I don't know.
Yay!
Oh, it's tax...
No, it's my property!
That's mine!
Toki!
Would you like to...
Oh my god, another one.
Trade it to her for the blue, maybe.
I don't know.
Yeah, Toki, I'll give you the light blue for the dark blue.
Wait, really?
For the red?
No, I want the dark blue.
I want the dark blue, though.
No.
But the red won't help him enough because he would have to get the third red from Hewn.
It's just gonna be too hard.
I'll take it for the red.
Or the pink.
Red or pink?
Take it or leave it.
Hewn will actually just dominate because he's the only one who can even buy houses right now.
Yay!
The rest of us are getting 20 bucks a pop from landing on spots.
You either get the red or pink.
That's my deal.
Red or pink.
I'm colorblind.
We should go with dark blue.
I'm also colorblind, but I can't see dark blue.
Shit!
She's buying houses right now.
Red or pink.
Dude, if you land on Baltic, that's $450.
$450 Smekis on one ball.
That's bad.
That's gonna be bad.
I wish you luck.
Dude.
No way, dude.
Why didn't you trade for this, man?
What do you mean?
You've been farming me.
What are you talking about?
That was my children's lunch money.
You just took it from me.
You know, honestly, screw your children's lunch money because you've been farming me the whole time.
I'm not backing you up.
What are you saying, man?
What are you saying?
You've been farming me.
I got $20 from you.
$20.
And I offered you the yellow for the record.
I offered you it.
I did.
He said, Kuno, I'll take the yellow and I'll give you the red.
I'm thinking you're giving me $50 right now.
That's right.
That's my train station that Ellen gave me.
Which means I screwed you over there, Dokia.
Oh, okay.
I guess I'll trade with Huun then.
No, wait, don't.
Huun.
Don't give her the dog food.
Don't give her the dog food, please.
I'll give you a yellow if you give me the red.
Sure, why not.
Guys.
Huun.
Wait, that's not a bad trade, I feel like.
Yellow for red is pretty fair, I guess.
I mean, at least you guys kind of cooked, though.
Huun, let me give you a counter offer.
You give me the red and I give you two of any color you like.
What?
Dude, Ellen, why are you trying to mess this deal up so bad?
Neither of them have monopolies.
Neither of them.
After this trade, you have a red and I have a yellow, right?
True!
So we hold the key that they need, and as long as neither of us folds, then we're tillin'.
Which, of course, we won't, right, Saikuu?
Yeah, neither of us are gonna fold.
Neither of us would fold, right?
Who wants the dark blue?
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Dude, dude, what happened to none of us fold?
What happened to neither of us fold?
I'm not gonna fold.
It's what I would've said.
It's what I would've said if I was being serious.
But of course, I'm not being serious, you know?
Yeah, listen, I have one yellow.
You have one red.
Neither of us fold, they got no power.
They just wasted their time with this trade.
They wasted their time, Ellen.
You and me, we're rock solid like Malphite from League of Legends.
Pinky and the Brain, baby, we got this.
We got it.
Here we go.
Neither of us fold and give up the yellow or the red.
Let me get the hell out of here, man.
Look at that.
Tycoon, I'll trade you a dark blue for your yellow.
Oh, I mean, I don't really need...
If you got the orange, though, I might think about it.
If I was willing...
If I was willing to fold, which I'm not.
Sorry, what are you saying?
You would think about it?
You said you were unfoldable on the first side.
That's what I said.
I said if I were willing to fold, which I'm not.
And then you straight away fold.
What do you mean?
I didn't.
She doesn't have the orange.
You instantly folded.
Dude, I said if I was willing to fold, which I'm not.
That's like saying if I had a million bucks, I'd buy you a Lamborghini.
What, you would?
A billion bucks, sorry.
Sorry, that was the greatest thing you ever said.
No, no, no.
I said a billion.
A billion, not one million.
One billion with a B.
With a B, yeah.
I just realized.
I thought about that.
States Avenue, I got the last pink.
You can't buy this property.
I'll give you a dark blue if you give me your red and pink.
Wait, is he deafened?
Oh, shit.
No, wait, no.
No.
No, nothing, nothing, nothing.
Yeah?
You're getting paid out a little bit, $20.
There it is.
I'm going into the trade.
Do you want it?
What are you doing?
If you give her the red, she's gonna kill her.
Let me just see what we're offering.
What happened to neither of us?
Yeah, what happened?
You think she'll give you the blue for the...
Oh, wait, she's actually giving you the blue.
Ellum, neither of us fold, remember?
If you give her the red, if you give her the red here, we're gonna be in a bad, bad spot.
Like, a lot of, like, really bad spot, man.
She's gonna have a monopoly.
She's gonna have a monopoly, Ellum.
Let me tell you.
Dude, don't give her the pink, too.
I'm not doing this.
This isn't me.
She's controlling this.
Oh, yeah, I know.
I mean, I'm just...
I'm innocent in this whole thing.
Dude, there's no way you accept this.
She's crazy.
Maybe one of them.
You don't fold.
You just don't fold.
If neither of us fold, the reds and the yellows will be locked down.
That's $2,000 if you can build a hotel.
They will be locked down, Ellum.
Locked down.
To be fair, you know, like, I'm looking at the value here, and if anything, it's better for me in a way.
But, you know, I mean, in a way, I'm just not.
Ellum, don't be a fool.
If you build a hotel, you get $2,000 for one thing you land on, Ellum.
$2,000.
Ellum, don't do it, man.
They're known to win you games.
The dark blue is what wins you the game.
I think they're actually the least likely to win you the game.
No, I won my last game with Broadwalk.
Did you?
Yeah, I won my last game with Broadwalk.
I won my last game with Broadwalk.
At least ask for some more money or something.
Put some money in.
Do you know what I mean?
Ellum, I'm never gonna trade this ever again if you don't accept the initial offer.
She's doing salesman tactics.
She's doing the walk away.
Don't fall for it.
This is a classic walk away tactic.
Ellum, all I'm saying is that this is the one time I'm doing this trade.
And if you don't take that trade, I'm trading with Sykuno.
Ellum, it's so easy.
That means you only have to say no once.
Offer it again.
You only have to say no once, Ellum.
You only have to say no once.
That's all.
He said no.
Ellum, don't give in, man.
He's gonna have all the reds.
We're gonna lose the game.
No, no, no.
Hit me out.
Okay.
What if I folded a tad?
Like a smidge.
Like a foldable chair.
I say at worst, do the blue for one red.
Blue for one red.
Come on.
Come on, Doki.
No, wait.
No, no, no.
Dude, we're folding.
No, don't do anything.
Just say no.
It's a classic.
Okay.
This is the only time I'm making this deal, Ellum.
If you don't trade with Sykuno.
I'm trading with Sykuno if you don't take this deal.
And you know Sykuno is gonna take the deal.
Ellum, you know I wouldn't take the deal.
You would.
You literally would take the deal.
The only reason I take the deal is that you took the deal.
That doesn't make sense because then that means if I would have already made the deal, then you can't take the deal because I would have already taken it.
I don't want the blue one.
I would trade her for a different one.
But if you do it, I'll be forced to.
Ellum, if you take this deal, I'll be forced to it.
She's gonna win the game.
Okay, hear me out.
I have nothing to lose here.
Sykuno, you've got nothing to worry about.
I'm gonna reject it.
Because me, I am unfoldable.
This means he's accepting it, bro.
Which means I'm accepting it.
Bro, this is the worst trade in the history of trade.
Ellum.
Look what you've done.
Look what you've done, you fool.
We're all going to lose now.
Oh my god.
Wait, that was a bad deal?
Dude, she just bought two houses.
She's crazy.
She's rich.
She's rich that I didn't even realize.
Ellum, we're in trouble.
We're in trouble.
Syk, trust in me.
Wait a second.
Wait, does that land you on the house in mind?
Wait, does it?
Thank you.
This is bad.
We're gonna get a monopoly at this point.
More money to upgrade my property.
Ellum, buy houses.
I'm buying houses.
Oh yeah.
Dude, you psychopath.
What do you mean?
This is good.
This is good for us.
I'm thinking of the long game of our team, bro.
What do you mean?
Our team, he says.
Our team, he says, as he takes the deal.
As he takes the deal.
I'm giving you the bingo guarantee that I won't fold again, okay?
That's the last time I'm folding.
You have nothing left to fold, bro.
I got a yellow.
Wait, you got the last yellow.
Okay.
Maybe that's good.
Yes.
Yes, I can.
What do you mean?
I'm not that...
Oh, dude, you barely can.
Yeah, barely.
I'm doing it.
Oh, this guy has $8.
Send me to jail.
He's going to land on a space and then he's going to go bankrupt.
That's good.
That's all good.
$200.
He got your $200 back.
Oh, yeah.
What do I do?
What happened to my dice on the side?
Six.
Wait a minute.
Hey, my railroad.
Oh, no.
Dude, this railroad is paying out for me.
It really is.
Railroads are nice.
Oh, boy.
Okay.
Um...
Dude, what do I even need here?
Like a three?
Don't fold.
You have one way to redeem this.
I said I wouldn't fold again, though, brother.
I said I wouldn't fold.
You're literally not folding.
Okay, I'm going to buy this thing for the good of the nation.
For the good of the nation.
And I'm going to give you a great deal.
Oh, man.
What's the deal?
What's the deal, man?
So, I'll tell you what.
I need that orange.
I need that orange real quick.
And then I'll give you...
Okay?
You want the yellow or the pink?
I want the...
How about the yellow and the pink?
Yeah, just get both.
I'll do you even better.
I'll prove that I'm a good business partner.
I'll give you the yellow pink.
And I'll even throw in a solid $30.
$30?
Dude, how's that?
Exactly.
And you know what?
I just did that for show because it's actually going to be $47.
Ask for the railroad, too.
Yeah, ask for the railroad.
Ask for the railroad.
Because it's been 47 spaces since we started our alliance.
This is our anniversary gift.
You can't say no to this deal.
You just can't.
$400 value.
$47.
Ask for the railroad, too.
You would give the railroad.
You're getting double the value here already.
It's a loan.
You know what?
This is my business partner right here.
Anniversary gift.
You're getting double the value.
Anniversary gift?
He's thoughtful.
I'll tell you what.
Doki wants that pink.
True!
Anything to piss off Doki.
Anything to piss off Doki is what I'm going to do.
Yeah, dude.
The funny thing is I actually misclicked and didn't enter the money on accident.
I just realized I misclicked.
You didn't even get the money.
You just got scammed.
Well, it's actually a misclick.
The UI is cooked.
You know the UI is cooked.
Stop buying houses.
Houses on houses.
He laughed, too, so you know you enjoyed that scam.
Alright, alright.
There ain't no way, bro.
There ain't no way.
You got double the value.
Yeah, I got double the value because then you scammed my ass.
What do you mean, bro?
What do you mean?
I'll tell you what.
You land on the properties, I don't charge you a cent, bro.
If you didn't offer it, then you wouldn't have felt scammed.
I don't charge you a cent if you land on the properties.
I'll tell you what.
You can't make that decision.
You barely own it.
You don't lose any.
It's the last one.
Dang it, I should have kept something saying, trade with Doki for the pink.
Ellum, trade that pink for the railroad.
Yeah, I'm winning the auction.
I'm winning the auction.
Oh, shit.
Dude, you're auctioning this?
Ellum, we need to win this, dude.
Dude, what do you mean, we?
What do you mean, we?
What do you mean, we here, brother?
We need this for the good of the nation, Ellum.
Then bid.
You can't bid on this.
No.
Why would you instantly go to 100?
At least make me think.
I think I have a chance.
At least give me like a little bit of hope.
It's perfect because Ellum can't bet on it.
I can't either.
I literally can't either, dude.
Oh my god.
So, Huynh, what would you trade for that railroad out of Kyrios?
Wait, Ellum, if you can rip that one yellow from Huynh, that would be...
Oh, he's gonna have to work really hard to get that from me.
Come on now, Huynh.
Huynh, come on.
Dude, you'll have triple yellow on that Ellum.
Huynh, what do you need from me?
What do you need?
Look, I'm open for suggestions, you know, whatever you need.
Came out a game as well, you know, you want me to...
I can play some embarrassing song with me singing, I can do...
Whatever you need, you know?
Whatever you need.
I don't know if she wants to pay money for that.
I don't know if that increases the value.
Six bucks to Doki.
I don't think she wants money.
I think she wants more than that.
Somebody lands on this orange and I call it a day.
Roll a, what, like a 3-4?
3-4?
3 -4?
Come on, 3 or 4?
3 or 4?
Dang it, dang it.
I mean, I don't know where I am, but...
Oh, hey!
36 buckaroos!
Oh, it's because it's doubled because she has all three.
You have all three.
Yeah, that's kind of crazy.
The houses are good.
I wonder who did that, Sykkuno.
Who gave me all those reds?
A two!
Wait, oh, it's him.
God damn it, man.
I want to... I got to go to prison.
I got to go to prison.
Surely.
Maybe it's time.
Yeah, I need to go to jail.
I don't want to go below 200 bucks here.
A three?
Then I lose money.
That's great.
Guys, I can't give Doki the other pink because there's nothing else I need, bro.
That would be absolutely devastating.
I just need money.
I would give Doki the other pink if she had a shitload of money she could just give me.
But I need money, bro.
I need money.
Oh, everybody's so poor now.
I know, it's bad.
Doki, please, please, please, please.
Please, cringe.
Everybody's so poor.
Wait, she lands on tax.
Tax.
Big tax.
Wait, that's... oh.
Is that tax?
Wait, but she gains 200 anyway, so she's... oh.
That's 200 bucks.
She loses 200.
No.
That's kind of a thing.
Dude, at least she didn't land on... look at those two houses on Hyun's property right there.
That would have been devastating.
Devastating.
She was one off.
Holy moly.
Let's see.
Wait, nobody has a green yet.
Yeah, that's kind of crazy.
Yeah, what the heck?
Yeah, nobody owns a green.
Please don't land on this orange.
I'm actually going to cry if I land on it.
I will actually have a breakdown.
No.
Why are you celebrating?
That's an orange.
Wow, you aren't brown.
No, he promised me 50% of the...
Give me 100 bucks plus the 47 bucks you owe me.
If he doesn't do that...
What?
Okay, yeah.
Trade me.
Trade me for the...
You said 147 bucks.
147.
147 bucks.
We'll call it a day.
Okay, okay.
50%.
Remember, business partners.
Or...
Or, I've got an idea.
Better idea.
Round it up.
You don't take the money now.
I buy two more houses.
And when they land on it, I'll give you double of what I owe you now.
You'll get 300.
You let me buy the houses to make more money.
You take that deal, you're a chump.
You let me take this money, okay?
You let me take this money, I buy two more houses, right?
They land on it, and you get 300.
But I get that anyway because you said I get 50% regardless.
Yeah, but I can't buy the houses.
See?
I can't buy the houses.
You take this money now.
Okay, good point, good point, good point.
You leave me with this money, I buy those houses.
Somebody else lands on it.
$300, you doubled your money.
How else are you gonna double your money in this game?
How else am I gonna buy houses on my own properties?
It makes simply sense.
Who wouldn't take that deal?
There's no other way you double your money that quick.
There's just no other way.
You can pass go, you only get 200.
You know what's gonna be funny?
Is LM gonna go bankrupt first?
Or you're gonna be able to buy the house?
I'm gonna be fine.
Oh, thank god I'm in jail.
Thank god.
Yeah, that's good.
$74 as well, bro, is nuts.
This is good.
$74.
Dude, LM, this is so good for us.
Let's play.
This is potentially the best situation we've ever been in.
LM, I'll...
I'll give you a green.
And $100 if you give me the light blue.
What is this?
Give me the green plus $100.
Yeah.
$22?
The light blue.
Okay, but I need a bit more money than that, though.
I need a bit more doki.
I rolled doubles?
Yeah, but that's more than what Sykuno gave you, which was zero.
Dude, I'm getting juiced out, bro.
That's money, baby!
Getting juiced out by money.
That's money!
I gave you this property.
Okay.
Wait, I only got $36?
Wait a second.
I need my money.
We're all poor.
Yeah, we don't have money.
Wait a second.
Please!
Did you buy any houses?
I did, brother.
You didn't buy any houses, did you?
Dude, LM, what happened to not charging each other?
Yes!
Oh my god!
I don't owe you a cent.
I don't owe you a cent anymore, man.
I don't owe you anything now.
You're paid back.
You're paid back, man.
Give me my money, bro.
You are extremely paid back now.
I call it even.
Dude, you are a scammer.
There's no way.
There's actually no way.
You call me a scammer?
$200 right off the bat right there.
$200?
You owe me $147, you dick.
What do you mean?
Which means you got an extra $60.
What a bargain that was.
I would never scam you, LM.
Yes, you would.
I would never.
I've given you good deals throughout it.
I want you to know in my entire chat, the moment I agreed to your deal, everyone just started spamming rolled.
Sorry.
All I'm saying, my value is $320 for the green.
I need money as well, Doki.
I need money as well.
You need money?
Alright, I'll give you money too.
And if you put like $1, I'm insta-rejecting.
I don't take any offers under $100.
$100 minimum.
$100 minimum?
Plus the property.
How about like $50?
No, no, no.
We're only talking $100 in this house.
How about $50?
How about $100?
What do you even want the green for?
It's not like it's gonna...
The green is the potential to get two other...
The green is the only one that has no prop.
That has no one else claiming it.
Yeah.
It's $1,400.
I mean, Ellum, you'll have two dark blues.
That's a very, very lucky already.
What I need right now, Doki, I'm gonna be honest, is just money.
I just need money.
I just need some big...
50 bucks.
Okay, how about this?
I'll give you the blue.
If you give me the pinks.
Both pinks?
I want both pinks.
I want both pinks for the blue.
This is my only deal.
Ellum, there's no way this makes sense.
This isn't even a fold at this point.
This is $370 to $120.
That's already double the money.
Doki, I accept your offer.
Doki, I accept it.
All I'm saying is that Sykkuno has fucked you over with money, but I actually put money in the deal.
Doki, Doki, Doki, Doki.
I actually, I believe and I think this is a good offer.
This is what I would say if I wasn't an idiot.
No.
Get refused.
Get rejected.
Can I trade you my green for your yellow?
Yeah, you can have my yellow.
No, no, no.
Ellum, don't.
Don't do it.
Ellum, don't put me in this position.
Ellum, this is stupid.
Just say no and walk away.
This isn't me.
This isn't me, bro.
Ellum, just say no.
Wait, Doki, can I get $10?
Yeah, of course.
How do I do this?
Ellum, just say no, bro.
Just say no.
That's all you gotta do.
It ain't that crazy.
It ain't that crazy, Ellum.
Just be like, nah, I ain't interested.
I ain't interested in your snake oil salesman.
I ain't interested.
Oh, sorry, I messed that up.
Wait a second, Hyun, you don't need to accept this.
Make the deal with me.
Make the deal with me, Hyun.
Oh, man.
Now you have to make the deal with her.
Wait a second.
Wait a second now.
Okay, okay.
Um, well, uh, Doki, what are you thinking here?
What are you, um...
What are you, uh...
What are you thinking right now?
Yeah, you want the yellow, right?
I mean, I would love the yellow.
You love the yellow, right?
I would really like the yellow, I'm not gonna lie.
Ellum, what happened to don't fold, bro?
You have to trade her the blue and the pink.
Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
You think I'm doing both?
Ellum, you ain't taking this deal, are you?
You don't take this.
Oh, and a hundred dollars, don't you?
Oh, and a hundred dollars?
And a hundred dollars.
You give me the yellow, I give you the light blue.
Right?
And we take away the money.
No, I only take two cards.
I'm holding the yellow.
Then I guess you're taking no properties.
Then how about you're taking no then?
Zero.
Zilch.
Nothing.
She's gonna land on the orange and she's gonna need the money.
She's gonna need the money.
She'll be forced to sell it at cheap.
Thank you.
And I'll sell it to Hyun.
But Hyun's got no money.
You can't sell it to her.
She's got nothing.
She's in jail, she will accumulate the wealth.
Shit, she's got a point.
I don't know if anyone lands on her stuff.
And she only, as of right now, Hyun only has brown.
Right?
Just think about it.
I have your last railroad sequel.
You ain't farming too much.
I can ask Hyun for the last railroad too.
Wait, what does Hyun have?
An additional backpack slot for you?
What the fuck is this?
Ellum, there's no way you accept this deal.
She's gonna have three monopolies with this.
Now doki doki doki.
She's gonna have more monopolies than the rest of the entire game.
Every time you land on my space, I'll give you back the money that you pay me.
That's, that's, that's, that's false.
I'll give you back the money that you land on my spot.
Ellum, you know you can't take this deal.
You know this.
Just think about it.
Every time you land on my space, I'll give you back the money.
Yeah, and you know why she's gonna have to give you back the money?
Because she took so much from you giving her all these.
You don't even need to get your money back.
I gave you Boardwalk, Ellum.
Boardwalk has been, like, one of the best spaces ever.
She scammed you.
Remember what Chat said when you gave Boardwalk?
They said Rolled.
They said I was spamming Rolled.
And then they said...
They just kept shouting Rolled at me.
Yeah, but didn't you earn $200 from Sykuno from Boardwalk?
I'm rejecting this offer.
I'm rejecting it.
It's done.
It's been refused.
Dude, she would have had three monopolies.
Three monopolies, doki.
I can't be dealing with that.
She's already got the red one, man.
She's already got the red one.
It would have been straight GG.
I don't even have enough money to buy houses.
Okay, doki, save the deal for a later time.
You know?
No, I'm not making that deal again.
No, no, no, doki, doki, doki.
Doki, doki, doki.
Sykuno, Sykuno.
Wait, oh my god, I'm fine.
Oh my god, thank god.
What do you mean by dang it?
I said dang it.
You didn't land on the chance space.
Nothing can happen to you here.
If you want, I'll take the deal because of what Sykuno just said.
No, Sykuno owes me 147 bucks still.
I don't have that money.
You took 200, remember?
That's not my fault.
I'm collecting my money right now.
I need somebody to land on my orange.
I'll make no money.
And now my chat is still saying rolled.
I got nothing, man.
If I land on a bad spot here, my keister's cooked.
What the fuck is a keister?
I don't know.
I heard Joey Wheeler say it in Yu-Gi-Oh.
Where does this land me?
Okay, 200 bucks.
200 buckaroos.
Imagine if you had given her the light blue.
This would probably be $200.
Yeah, but it would only be on you, Sykuno.
It doesn't affect Elem in any way.
True.
How am I going to pay you back?
You could technically pay him back right now.
But with what money?
He just spent his money.
How am I going to pay you back if I only have $100?
But why are you spending the money you owe me?
I'll offer the deal one more time, Elem.
Wait, where does this land me?
Where does this land me?
Wait a minute.
Dude, no.
That's not even the one.
Elem, I'll give you this deal one last time.
It's not the worst.
Hit me out.
You give me the yellow.
I give you the light blue.
That's too much.
Dogi, that's too much.
Every time you land on my...
I've been giving you everything.
I give you boardwalk too.
And then every time you land on my monopolies, I'll pay you back.
You don't even have to pay on my property.
How about the rest of the people?
Think of the common folk, Elem.
What happens when I land there, man?
I'm going to die.
You're getting Zangief grabbed right now.
She's pushing one button and it's working.
You know what's crazy?
The moment I land on the other blue, he goes, I owe you nothing.
And then I said, give me the $147.
And then he goes, and then he starts spending the money.
I don't have $147.
You started spending the money, you owe me.
I'll make sure you'll never have to pay any of the property if you land on it.
That's because you'll be out of the game after that.
You don't have to pay anymore because you'll be donezo.
I'll give you $50 as well.
Elem, you're going to be rolled and smoked again.
What's chat saying?
If you listen to me, you'll win the game.
I bet you your chat is saying rolled right now.
Your chat will say rolled for every decision you make, Elem.
They're just saying do it.
Don't do it, Elem.
They're going to say do it and then say rolled if you accept.
That's exactly what they're doing.
I promise you.
They're going to call the bingle rolled.
Your chat will say the same thing.
You want to be known as the bingle rolled?
Is that it?
Dude, they're all just going do it and nope.
This is like a 50-50 split.
This isn't helping, chat.
This isn't helping.
But I would like two monopolies.
Elem, think about this for one second.
You get this monopoly and what?
You buy houses on it?
Yeah, and then Sykuna will land on it.
You don't have house money.
Sykuna already landed on boardwalk.
Remember that.
Give her two monopolies.
And then not be able to buy houses.
Give me money as well.
I'll even make sure to be faithful.
I forgot to put the money in there.
Do a counter offer.
I'll put $50 in.
50 buckaroos?
Dude, Elem, ask for 100.
Sykuna slammed you and didn't even put the money in.
100 bucks.
150 so you can buy a house.
150 bucks, come on.
So you can buy a house.
And then we gotta do it.
Property comes with a house, that's a fair deal.
That's 165.
Wait, why is it going down so fast?
I'm not clicking anything.
Is that me?
Wait, doki.
I didn't do anything.
You ran out of time.
Okay, 150 bucks.
The two, plus, and then I get the yellow.
You gotta do it.
Okay, sure.
That's crazy.
Plus the T's and C's you said though.
If I land on you, you'll give me the money back.
Yeah.
Why did you say it like that?
That's just how I talk.
Elem, if she lands on a property after she gives you 150 bucks, she can't even give you the money to pay her back.
How about I'll give you $100?
$100?
$125.
$105.
$106.
$110.
$110?
$107.
$109.
What's your offer?
I pressed it wrong.
In which case, because of that mistake, I'm charging you a premium of $125.
Oh.
Yeah, that sounds fair.
$125.
Come on now.
Dude, this is such a great deal.
Right?
Deal.
Trading is the heart of business.
It's a good deal for somebody.
How about $120?
Okay, $120.
What's your offer?
Wait, I don't know the way she said that.
Oh, wow.
Flavin, you said okay.
So, I mean, you just got it.
My value is higher than yours.
There's one person I know who wouldn't lie to me and that's Hyun.
Hyun, I would like to go to my financial advisor.
Is this a good deal?
Huh?
You're now officially my financial advisor.
What do you mean?
Hyun wouldn't betray me.
She wouldn't betray me.
That's because she's never on your side.
She can't betray you.
Well, what do you want more?
Like, I mean, you're...
Do you want Sykkuno to lose more?
Or do you want to lose?
There you go.
We can both win, Elem.
And now we're going to be fine because now I have money, brother.
I can do this far.
Sykkuno, you're such a dick.
Sykkuno, I...
You're such a dick.
You're the one who's spamming it in my chat, you asshole.
Dude, your chat is spamming it right now, dude.
This is crazy that you've done this.
It's crazy that you've incited the masses.
They're spamming rolled again.
No, because now Doggy can't even buy houses.
Look, dude, look, look.
She's so broke.
Land on Orange.
If she lands on Orange, there's a justice in this world.
No!
Dude, she skipped all the Oranges.
No shot.
It's over, Elem.
It's over.
Oh, hey, it's my property.
No!
Yeah, she has a monopoly.
She's got three monopolies, Elem.
Because of you!
What are you saying because of me?
Are you insane?
You're lying to me.
You just gave her two monopolies.
I don't even know what you're even talking about.
You can't just pay because of me.
I don't even know what to believe anymore.
I don't even know what to believe anymore, okay?
All men do is lie.
Someone's spam rolled.
If I land on a property right now, I'm going to go scorch it.
I'm going to break something.
Oh, thank Christ.
That's finally paying out.
Thank you.
Give me the money back.
Come on, please.
Money back?
You're my financial advisor.
You're my money.
The financial advisor.
What do you mean?
I'm in jail.
I have no money.
I hope you say that.
Brought in prison.
Oh, man.
Does she have to buy out yet?
No, she can do it for two more.
Two more turns.
Oh.
No way.
We love that.
I like being in my little safe space.
Yeah, just earning money without having to go.
Did she just buy more houses?
Bro, we're so freaking broke right now.
This is bad, guys.
This is...
I'm not getting rolled.
It's going to be fine.
I'm not getting...
He's getting death rolled by a crocodilius right now.
I'm not.
I'm going to be fined.
A crocodilius?
Got him.
No.
Look at this, Ellen.
This is because of you.
This blood is on your hands, Ellen.
What do you mean?
It's literally on you.
I don't even know.
You know what?
You gave her the pinks.
I've been blaming you this entire game.
You really gave her the pinks.
Dude, you owe me 147 bucks still.
Give me the money.
Enjoy your one dollar.
I'm collecting my money right now.
You can give me your orange as well.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
I need someone to land on it so I actually have money.
Wait, 48 bucks.
48 buckaroos, man.
Yeah, yellow.
Remember what I did?
I gave you that yellow.
Please just be fine.
That's almost 50 bucks with no...
Yes.
And then with this, I buy more.
I buy another house.
Another house, guys.
That's a game ender, bro.
That is a game ender.
If I land on that, that's a bomba.
Yeah, I love being in here.
I love being out here.
Nice.
Just chilling in jail.
Wait, she's out.
She misses all the oranges.
You can always decide what's going to happen to you.
Advance to New York.
Yeah, you get to go to jail!
That makes sense.
Dude, Yoon is having the best luck ever.
This is insane.
No way, dude.
This is a good day.
Bro, she's just in jail building properties.
What in the name of fraud is this?
Is this BS, dude?
She can't be doing this.
This is insane.
Now's a good time to think about your next move.
Please, for the love of god, I swear, I want her to land on my property so fucking bad, you have no idea.
I need to go to prison.
Please land on my property.
Wait a minute.
Yes!
Oh my god, yes!
Wait, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
No, no, no.
Doki?
Doki, what are you...
Dude, you don't have enough money.
She's gonna have mortgage stuff.
Doki?
That's fine.
Can I give an IOU of 136 since you're in jail?
The game has completely turned around with one bad roll.
That's crazy.
Doki?
Oh my god.
Wait, what's the strat here?
What's the...
What are you trying to...
What are you trying to do right now?
You could mortgage the properties and still pay it off.
It would be fine.
Wait, what is this?
Yeah, but then I can mortgage less.
It's an IOU.
You're trying to take the money from Hyun on an IOU?
Dude, Ellen, why can't our team make...
Dude, Ellen, why isn't our team like this, man?
Dude, no, okay, from this point on, from this point on...
Dude, look at them covering each other.
Dude, this is us.
You can't even spot me 147 bucks in my house.
I'm homeless on the streets.
No, I got you, bro.
Come on in.
The water's warm, brother.
I've run you a bath.
I've got some food ready, okay?
She's gonna have to mortgage, though.
Time to mortgage, Doki.
Time to mortgage.
I'm gonna have to mortgage a lot.
I'll tell you what, I'll buy...
Dude, I have no money either.
I can't even make a deal.
I'm broke.
I can't even...
I have 100 bucks.
Bro humbled himself so quickly then, that was Chris.
I mean, I'd like to try and make a deal, but there's just no deal I can make at this point.
With 148 bucks, it's not...
Dude, Ellum might win this one.
Well, I mean, he's just about to get, like, $500.
Yeah, he's just about to get $500.
500 buckaroos, bro!
500 buckaroos!
Oh my god, Ellum's about to win the whole damn game.
Yes, dude!
You know, I'm okay with Ellum winning, as long as Sykkuno doesn't win.
But a win for me is a win for Sykkuno, you know?
Exactly, out of curiosity.
I feel like I've done nothing.
I've done nothing but look up to you.
I've seen how you do your deals.
I've done nothing but look up to you as a fellow Zangiefa.
And if you've done all of that just to lose, that's my victory.
Dude, I only have one property.
I only got an orange.
That's barely anything.
Dude, Ellum's gonna win though, not gonna lie.
That landing spot is epic.
Dude, this game hates you.
That's absurd.
This game just doesn't want you to win.
That's fine.
If I know who's gonna lose, that's fine.
The fact that you try to scam Ellum so many times.
And if he wins that game...
Whoa, whoa, I didn't scam him.
Let me get one of them there real quick.
I could.
I could do a third one.
Dude, if anybody, Ellum's actually gonna win.
If anybody lands on these landmines...
You know what?
We're gonna leave it at that right now.
It's so GG.
Ellum got this in the bagging tin, as they say.
Oh yeah.
Dude, we need Huynh to roll like an 8.
What is going on with my 8?
This is good.
This is very, very good.
Oh, she did roll an 8, but not a double.
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
Dude, that 8 would have been massive for me.
It just would have been massive.
Dude, if I land on that blue, I don't think I can even come back.
I don't think I can even come back.
Yes!
Huge!
Oh my god.
He went to jail.
Let's go!
Jail time, brothers.
There's no shot, dude.
He's gonna go in jail, and then he's gonna get out of jail next turn.
Oops.
No, no, that's right.
You owe me 147 bucks.
Give me my money.
Stop spending my money.
He's not gonna give you your money back.
He's not gonna give you that money.
As soon as I take the money back, Dude, what if I land on it?
What if I land on it, bro?
I'll send the money back to you.
I'll have to mortgage my properties, bro.
What do you mean?
It's only 300 on the orange.
It's only 300.
And I'll send it right back.
We got a deal.
Are you sure?
Will you actually?
Yeah, 100%.
Land on it and find out.
Okay, okay.
Land on it twice and find out.
I'll land on it right now.
Now you said twice.
Just to double proof it.
Oh, that's for you.
Thank you.
Stop taking my money from me.
Why do you keep doing this?
Oh my goodness.
Well, you know, I'm just a little...
You should stop landing on your property.
You might have to mortgage something after this.
No!
60 bucks.
Oh my god.
Finally, it's paid out.
Finally.
The years of waiting.
Finally, St. James is popping, boys.
$550.
Yeehaw, cowboy.
That's the money I needed.
Oh my gosh.
I'll give you a deal.
I don't know how she crawls out.
I'll give you all the money I have.
Even if she mortgages everything.
I'll give you my property, the mortgage.
Oh my god.
Can I have my 140 bucks now?
I'll tell you what.
I'll give you the double just as promised.
Oh my god, he did what he did.
Yes, the guarantee.
The guarantee.
You forgot.
You forgot about the double deal.
And he reminded me of it.
Because if there's one thing I ask people to do, it's to judge me on how many times I scam you because it's so few times.
Yeah, I'll give you my property.
Isn't that a quote from Wolf of Wall Street?
Yeah, it is.
It is.
The ones that aren't mortgaged yet.
Because there's so few of them.
Judge me on my losses because there's so few of them.
Yup.
And we got some big wins.
Listen, Ellen, you just won a $500 landing.
I just got a $500 landing.
We got the teamwork.
We're the A team right now.
We both win.
We both win this.
You ever see the boys?
You're like Homelander right now and I'm like I don't know, man.
I'm like Who would I be?
I actually haven't watched the boys.
I'm not even gonna lie.
No, no, no.
How much do you need?
She needs $550.
I think $550.
Dude, look at this perfect synchronization between these right now.
It's crazy.
I'm trying to figure out what is the most like I am so good at my chances going police so I'm just like you know.
Dude, he's not you.
This is what we call a team.
An alliance.
We're winning.
Okay?
We're up right now, guys.
We're up.
We are up.
On top.
This is it.
Should I just do this?
I don't know what's the best here.
I buy more houses.
Okay.
That could just...
What does that mean?
Is that enough?
Wait, no.
Don't say that.
I need $10.
I need $9.
He sleeps with an octopus.
He sleeps with a what?
With an octopus.
He's a guy who...
I didn't know that.
Is that even possible?
He's an aquatic hero, basically.
Yeah, that's kind of weird.
He's like the deepest.
It's crazy.
Then how do I collect this whole thing?
Oh, we're winning.
We're winning, dude.
Well, the thing about winning is that only one person can win, so which one out of you two are going to be the real winner?
And a win for Sykuno is a win for me.
That's what they always say.
The team work's kicking in.
The boys.
They doubted our strength.
They did.
They literally did.
And now look at us.
But I'll tell you what...
Hey, Elem, if I trade the rest of my property to you, will you break the alliance with Sykuno?
And I'll just declare bankruptcy?
What?
You think I would do that?
We could both win.
They're desperate, Elem.
There could only be one winner, Elem.
But does there need to be one winner?
We both win.
The only way for this game to end is if all the players except for one lose this game, is if we break up our teamwork.
Syk, my chat is saying, do it, do it, do it.
The only way we even have a chance of losing is by breaking up the team right now.
We're dominant.
We're A-side right now.
Do you know what I mean?
At this point, why fold?
Why even think about it, man?
We can't lose.
Syk, so you give me the hundred...
Wait, where did my money go?
Syk, you're gonna give me the money.
What do you mean?
I haven't got paid yet.
They're still mortgaging.
Oh, I see.
I see.
You give me that money, and you don't suddenly just start building properties, then we'll keep the alliance.
Here's a crazy idea.
I double it again.
Shut the fuck up.
You don't want $600?
$300 is enough for you.
That's all you want?
You just want $300?
I thought you were a monopoly player.
You still have more mortgages.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You tell me right now, Ellum, who else can offer you $600 on the board?
Okay, wait, Ellum.
What if I gave you...
my property and my waterworks and the last railroad?
What?
I'm just saying, Ellum.
No, nothing.
I'm just about to die.
I mean, I have nothing.
What if, like, Kuhn and I give you everything?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can give you everything.
Yeah, we'll give you everything.
Just think about that.
Let's think about this, Ellum.
You're gonna take the deal of two desperate people with no properties or you're gonna take a deal from me, a successful businessman offering to double your money.
Look at this.
No, I bought a house in the countryside.
I'm ready to retire.
Look at my crazy offer here.
Yeah, look at this crazy offer.
I can't give you this, but here.
This is everything else that I have.
That's actually a lot of value.
That's a lot of value.
Yeah.
For what?
For 300 bucks?
No, just to win.
Okay, well sure then.
Yeah, just so you can win.
Just so I can win.
Imagine how much Sykkuno's pride is gonna hurt to lose against Ellum.
To lose in a 3v1 against Ellum?
I don't think I'd feel too bad.
What's your opt?
After all the hard work he's spent In a 3v1 against me?
to try and win this game.
I'll take the properties I get.
Well, here's the funny thing.
I'm going bankrupt.
Dude, you didn't even force Ellum to break the alliance.
Now we're just even stronger.
Now we're even stronger than before.
We're undefeatable now.
It's over.
Do you like Deku?
When you know it's like that possibility You can make him go plus ultra, but then they kind of latch onto it.
That's me and you right now.
We're going plus ultra.
Keep the mortgage.
Oh god.
Holy shit.
Wait, I only have 300 bucks?
Oh, it's because she bankrupted.
My money.
It's just like my 147 bucks you were doing.
No money allowed.
I'll tell you what, Ellum.
Let's up it to $600.
$600?
$147.
Ellum, listen.
You can listen to everyone else, but I'll tell you what, I'm a successful businessman.
I need to pay $500.
Who else on this planet right now, in this game, right now, can offer you $600?
Other than me.
Who you've seen has made $550 off of that.
I'm offering you a deal no one else can on this entire planet.
Wait, you already spent the money before I accepted.
That's because it's such a good deal that anyone with a brain would have accepted it.
You, Salah, you're quoting Wolf of Wall Street.
I was so sure.
That if you'd accepted, that if you didn't, you'd be hurting.
Dude!
Yo, Ellum, this is it, bro!
This is it!
Huge comeback.
I got the highest KDA in this game, I'm just saying.
Winner, loser, I got the highest KDA is all I'm saying.
Jesus Christ.
That's it.
You see, Ellum?
You want that $600?
I just got you $750.
$750.
I want it in cash.
But unfortunately, no one is paying in cash.
They're paying in alternate methods.
It's really awkward, actually.
I mean, they ain't giving me this cash.
I can't give it to you either.
I don't really know what to do with that.
Oh, God.
Did she even give you the jail card?
That's crazy.
She's giving me everything she has.
Oh, God.
Dude, where did it go so wrong?
I feel like we were so down bad, and then suddenly he got switched in one turn.
I mean, it just was that one landing on your blue, and then they both landed on my orange, and it kind of finished it off.
It's alright, because Sykuno gets nothing from me.
Wait, I'm going to pay to remortgage this?
Wait, I'm going to repay the mor...
Or you keep the mortgage, but you don't do anything with it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would just not repay it.
It has no houses, anyway.
Yeah, it has nothing on it.
Wait a second.
So now that I go bankrupt, Sykuno gets nothing from me.
Dude, it's actual...
Actual everyone's against me.
But I'll tell you what, I got the highest pay.
I got one dollar.
If I land on his one, I land on his fucking one.
Are you actually joking?
There is no way that I'm gonna...
No, no, no.
Give me the money back.
No, you give me the money back.
You promised me you would give me the money.
No, I won't send it right back, but you do have to mortgage some stuff, otherwise, like, you know, it might be over.
Wait, everything's already...
Oh shit.
Wait a second.
Guys.
Mortgage?
You chose your alliance.
You knew exactly how it was gonna go with that alliance.
Wait, guys.
Guys.
You're gonna have to mortgage some houses.
I'm not gonna lie, but it is for the good of the nation.
And now you'll give it back to me, right?
Well, I said I'd give it back to you, but now that you've allied with Dokian Heu...
I didn't know you'd give me my money.
Give me my $700,000 back.
I didn't bring the money.
Give me my money back.
You broke the alliance first.
I'd give my partner the money back.
You gave me the money back.
You took their property!
They gave it to me!
They forced me!
They handed me the contract in the post!
You could have rejected the deal!
I didn't have the option!
There's no way!
There's literally no way!
Are you actually joking right now?
You're spending my money!
Right in front of me!
That's my money!
I'm spending my company's money that you left!
That I didn't leave when I didn't hand in my notice period!
Show me the contract!
You could have said no!
Everyone is saying rolled!
I'm not being rolled!
You accepted the 3v1!
I would have had an honourable battle at the end!
But you accepted the 3v1 battle!
You betrayed first!
You just said that me and you were getting stronger!
Because they gave it to me for free!
Because they didn't even accept the deal!
You're right!
We both win!
So give me my money!
If I get a 3, so fucking hell with me!
Oh my god!
I just missed!
We could just both quit the game now!
And we both win!
You first!
Let's just both quit the game and we both win!
Why don't you guys do a countdown?
I'll do a countdown and then you both quit the game at the same time!
Yeah sure!
I'll do the countdown guys!
5...
4...
3...
2...
1...
You guys are still playing!
You could just quit when you both win...
Yeah it makes sense but...
Are you fucking kidding me bro?
You could literally just quit right now!
Let me get another countdown!
Oh guys did you, is it because I lagged?
I'll do another countdown!
5...
4...
3, 2...
1...
Did you mortgage this one?
Oh, it's the one not mortgaged.
Give me my 22 bucks.
If I land on the blue though, I'm actually going to be in trouble, dude.
This is going to be...
Please, I pray you get completely screwed.
I pray.
I am praying on your downfall.
Dude, it's a 3v1 at this point.
I'm the underdog.
I am praying on your literal downfall right now.
What happened to the alliance, guys?
Oh, that shit is bugged.
That shit has bugged.
The alliance is just gone.
I am going for your jugular.
The alliance is just gone like that?
For your jugular like a goddamn pitbull right now, bro.
I bet you guys were voting.
I'll tell you what, I could buy this property, but I'll auction it to be fair.
How's that sound?
You're an asshole, bro.
I have 99 bucks.
What do you mean?
Just withdraw because he paid me.
Just withdraw from it.
He's done it because I can't.
He just outbid me in one...
Now that's how you do business.
I gave you a fair shot.
You mean you gave me a fair shot?
What do you mean you gave me a fair shot?
What do you...
Dude, if I land on that blue one, I swear, I pray.
He might land on your blue one.
You never know.
Oh, he's safe.
I don't want a double.
Dude, if I land on that blue though, I'm actually into so much.
Give me my 200 bucks.
Dude, you know what?
Actually, honestly, hang on.
I've got an idea.
Just because I want him to land on this so freaking badly.
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
You can get on mortgage it.
How do I...
Why can I not...
I want to...
You have to pay for the mortgage.
I don't want to pay for the mortgage.
But you have to pay for the mortgage.
No.
Then don't.
I want to manage my properties.
That's like Kuno's property.
Wait, I own that one.
I own that one.
Oh, yeah.
No, hey.
That's like Kuno's property.
And I wish you luck for when you land on this.
I wish you luck for when you land on this, okay?
Holy Jesus, bro.
Thank you so much.
1,400?
I think that actually would end the game.
Thank you so much.
I mean, at this point, it comes down to the roll.
Oh, it comes down to this last roll.
Oh, the roll is going to be...
No!
Wait a minute.
Wait a second.
He lives.
Wait.
Wait, that puts me on...
One past it!
He actually lives!
That's dangerous.
That's a dangerous one, man.
Brother!
I hope you roll a 10 or an 11.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to cry.
It would be so beautiful to land a 10 or 11 here.
I'm fine, right?
Fine, right?
What property is that?
I think it's mine, actually.
Oh!
Sometimes...
Oh, as long as I get past it.
As long as I get past it, that's fine.
Just got to get past the danger.
I mean, you have to...
Dude, you have to roll so low here.
You have to be past four.
The only way Sykkuno can get fucked is if he gets...
Wait, no.
This is funny.
The only way Sykkuno can get fucked is if he gets a card that takes him to boardwalk.
Yeah, that would be the one way to lose.
Yeah, that would be...
That would be a funny one.
Heartbreaking.
Dude, come on.
Give him a 3-4.
Please.
3-4.
3 -4 right here.
For the love of God, you give me a 3-4, I'm going to lose my...
I will lose my fucking life.
3-4.
Two!
Oh, my God.
Yes.
Dang it.
Oh, my God.
That two looks good.
That two looks good at first.
Oh, my God.
That is mine.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Yes.
Dude, it's just whoever lands on the next one.
It's GG.
Six.
Next landing is it.
Yeah, but you have a long way to go.
That's me.
No!
Oh, it's mortgage.
It's the battle of the mortgage.
Send me the Joe.
It's just all going to come down to if I land on the blue or for you to land on the blue.
Oh, wait.
Shit.
This is bad.
It's going to go closer to my property.
I love what you're doing.
No, please.
Send me to jail.
Don't go to jail.
No.
Another double.
Yes.
Dude, there's no way, bro.
Big, big, big.
There's actually not.
Oh, please.
Please.
You're good.
No.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
What is this RNG?
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Low roll.
Low roll, please.
For the low roll.
Low roll.
Not jail.
Isn't that the middle, like, weird one?
It is.
Yeah, that's the weird one.
I think you lose some money.
Oh.
Oh, 100.
Still, overall, plus 100.
I mean, you got 200, lost 100.
It's your turn.
You almost got to jail.
As long as I don't land on that blue, I'm chilling.
Shit.
It's bad.
That's nice.
No, man.
You got another 200, though.
That's not good.
Free parking.
Come on.
We need them to land on an orange.
This is orange.
Orange.
Dude, why is it always giving me doubles the whole time?
Like, what is...
Wait, hang on.
If that's a tax, I'm going to lose my money.
That's not a double.
That's a five.
Wait.
No way I gave you 60 bucks.
Wait, I have houses there.
Why does he have houses there?
That's the hoon's houses.
You know what, bro?
Enjoy that.
Because that grenade's going to go off.
That grenade's going to go off in your face, bro.
Okay?
That grenade's going to go off in your face.
Whoever lands on the next big one, it's GG.
Holy Christ.
Please.
But the thing is, your time has come.
Roll them as close to the...
Roll low, roll low.
Yeah, the...
Yeah.
Not bad.
Oh, I think he owns this one, right?
Don't you own this one?
Or...
Is it mortgage?
No, you own that.
Oh, you own that one.
Okay, not bad.
Low roll, low roll, low roll.
I just got to keep rolling low and not hit.
Low roll, brethren.
Low roll.
That's not low.
That's too big.
That's so good for you, though.
You're right before the oranges.
So you have a high chance of making it through.
Oh my God.
Yes.
And that's good.
Oh.
Yes.
It's your turn.
Dude, I'm getting...
I could land on a blue ride.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
It's a double.
Okay, not bad.
Not bad.
That's fine.
I'm right before the blues.
I'd have to get such an unlucky roll to land on a blue at this point.
What number?
I have to roll for less than four.
Yeah, like a four.
Oh, yes.
Oh my God.
No way.
It's over.
That's such an unlucky roll.
Hold that big L, you.
There's got to be something I can do.
Yes.
14.
1,400 bucks.
Okay, okay.
Wow, you are so back in business.
You're absolutely so back.
Dude, we're so back.
Surely there's something I can do.
Yes.
You have to un-mortgage L.
You have to un-mortgage your stuff with this.
Yes, we are so back.
And surround Sykuno.
We are so back.
1,400.
1,400?
1,400, dude.
Yeah.
1,400 bucks right there, dude.
That's even possible.
I mean, I'll try to play it out, but I feel like I lose.
No, no, you can do it with the hotels.
You know, you could get rid of those.
Yeah, you gotta get rid of the hotels.
But if I get rid of the hotels, I lose anyway, so it's like...
Well, not necessarily.
Yeah, you might have a chance.
I definitely lose, Syk.
If I don't have at least a few times, that ain't come back to me.
Dude, the doki plan worked.
The doki plan worked.
Dude, the orange Jesus.
That's crazy.
There's a 1PG.
Give me my money, baby.
Give me my money.
Excellent.
Is it even possible?
Yeah, yeah.
I can get rid of it.
That's so...
I mean, if you land on that, it's still pretty lethal.
7,750 is pretty punchy.
Okay.
I mean, that's enough, but at this point, it's just...
Dude, look at that.
Oh, my God.
See where he is and un-mortgage all the stuff on that pathway.
Yeah, actually.
Jesus.
Go to your property and un-mortgage everything.
No way.
He rolled past it again.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
I mean, it just comes down to pure luck at this point.
Oh, I can feel it.
Wait.
No, it's fine.
Oh, man.
Un-mortgage railroad.
All right.
Remember to un-mortgage.
Go to my properties and un-mortgage.
Yeah, yeah.
You got to...
Spare key.
Yeah.
What do I do?
Look at the...
Dude, how did this actually turn into a 3v1?
How did this actually turn into a 3v1?
So, you see where he is?
He's at the blue.
So, un-mortgage your light blue and then un-mortgage the pinks.
Oh, I see.
I see.
So, now he's trapped in this area.
Very good.
Now he's scared.
Yeah.
Now he's very scared.
And then remember the pinks as well, too.
Wait.
Why is that one so locked?
Because he owns that.
He owns that.
Oh, he owns that one.
Yeah.
The only other monopoly you have is like what?
Like yellow?
Oh.
Yeah.
Then un-mortgage all the pinks.
I don't have them.
Oh, yeah.
It's really only worth going for the yellows at this point.
Not going to lie.
Is it?
Oh, wait.
I guess actually, yeah.
Honestly, you know what?
I should just get rid of them all.
Honestly, at this point, I'm just going to get them all.
You're just going to give him a death trap.
The reds are good.
Get the reds.
Get some of these done.
Very good.
Wait.
Why am I building houses?
Why am I?
I'm not going to be building houses.
What do you mean?
Wait.
I don't know.
And then you're safe.
All right.
Buy a house.
Dude, you could hotel on the blues.
Dude, you could hotel the blues.
That'd be chicken.
Yes.
I mean, if I land on another blue, the game...
Dude, look at that.
Look at that.
Look how scary that is, Navi.
Oh, baby.
Okay.
Who does nine go?
Please.
Oh, he has to pay.
Oh, you own the property.
He was just lucky enough.
Oh, God.
Guys, we should spend it all because he's a danger zone.
Okay, here we go.
This is so over.
I wish you luck.
He's not even close to the oranges.
He has a death trap.
I said...
Wait.
Oh, I'm one plus.
I'm literally one plus.
Okay.
I think.
We'll pass.
You're on like a green or something, right?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, but he's mortgaged it.
Mortgage.
Okay.
Very good.
Like 10 bucks.
It's all just going to come down the rolls here.
If I land on another...
No way.
It's taking me closer to the blues.
Yeah.
Bring him to me.
More money, baby.
12 fuckers.
Like these don't matter.
It's just orange or blue at this point.
Oh, yeah.
It's orange or blue.
That's the death trap.
Yeah.
There's no other game here.
It's just orange or blue.
Oh, yeah.
Whoever landed orange or blue.
Home sweet home.
Oh, yeah.
You thought about it.
It's just orange or blue.
This is delightful.
That's it.
There's nothing else to it.
Come on now.
Wait.
I think it's...
Oh, no.
Wait.
I think I lose 100 bucks.
Don't I?
I don't think so.
No.
Oh, wait.
You do.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Dude.
No way.
You're going to get it back.
I mean, at this point, it's genuinely just orange or blue.
It's just up to your guys' luck.
If it's orange, I have a chance to come back.
God damn it, man.
Dude.
How do I roll a double?
That little flag trolled me.
Here we go, brother.
That little flag trolled me, dude.
Sometimes $48 of gold broke out your hand.
Never give up.
Oh, man.
Hey, that's only 100 bucks more, man.
That's the money you owe me anyway.
You know?
There you go.
How do I roll another eight?
Another one.
Dude.
I think that lands me.
I think it's over.
Is it over?
It is.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
It's over.
Dude.
I don't know.
I landed on it twice.
It's just bad luck.
That's it.
Dude.
They didn't even have to 3v1.
I just landed on it twice.
Barnacle Bing.
Ellen, I told you.
The moment you have the dark boardwalk, you win, Ellen.
Dude, that really did win.
Jesus.
I told you.
Boardwalk wins games.
It's a W.
Do you guys want to do it?
Do you guys want to do one more?
No, I'm good.
She just...
She just said, nope.
That's my moral victory.
Oh, God.
Jesus.
That was intense.
Sykkuno losing to Ellen is my victory.
Oh.
I lost to three people, technically.
That is true.
What do you mean?
Technically, I was supposed to get them all, but...
A win for Ellen is a win for all of us.
Exactly.
Do you guys want to play anything else?
Do you guys want to play any other games at all?
Play good games, guys.
I mean, I'm down for games.
Yeah.
I'm down for whatever.
I can play for another one hour, because I have a coaching thing at 5.
Do you want some Tricky Towers or something?
Yeah, I was.
Another hour?
Tricky Towers?
Yeah, what is that?
Oh, we can do GeoGuessr or anything.
Honestly, I'm down for whatever.
Whatever you guys want to play.
I'm down for anything.
Same.
So, if you guys have any...
Deciding games.
Yeah, me too.
I'm like, what do you play?
I mean, literally anything.
You know, GeoGuessr.
Tricky Towers.
Fool Guys.
We can play Risk.
Risk.
We do Risk as Risk.
Risk is going to go to another strategy game.
Oh god, the Risk is going to be...
Wait, do you want to do Risk?
You actually want to do that?
I'd be down.
I actually would be down for Risk.
I feel like Risk is a really long game.
Or it can be really long.
Not the way me and Syke play it.
Me and Syke just int each other the whole time.
Um, otherwise, there's...
Watch out.
Game of Life.
Game of Life is going to be...
It's going to be fun.
Um, uh, honestly, I'd be down for Risk.
I'd be down.
Risk.
You could do that or Roblox.
Once again, I'm on more risk.
Anita, thank you for the raid!
Yeah!
Wait, Alan hasn't finished...
Dude, we could do Doors.
I'm honestly down for one of them.
I'll be back in one second though.
Anita, thank you for the raid!
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello!
Doors.
Yeah.
The only thing is that I can't set up the lobby because I don't know how to.
But I'm definitely down for Doors.
I'm down.
I'm definitely down.
Dude, can we do...
Can we do Roblox Party as well?
Can we do Doors and Roblox Party?
Because I actually loved it.
We can do Roblox Party.
Yes!
Okay, that's actually fine.
Let's do that.
Wait, what's Roblox Party?
Dude, it's so fucking good, dude.
Um, Anita, thank you for the raid!
Hello, everybody.
Welcome in.
If you guys don't know me, I'm Joshua Elam.
Um, Anita, I want to play games.
I feel like also we stream like around the same time now because I'm always on like a PSD schedule.
I want to play games.
I miss you.
Um, but anyone from my stream, obviously, I'm sure you guys all know exactly who Anita is.
If you don't, please make sure you guys go and drop a follow.
She's awesome.
I love Anita.
Also, I hope you're going to TwitchCon because I'm going to be there.
That's going to be awesome.
Um, how do I know...
Blah, blah, blah.
Sorry, chat.
I'm like...
So guys, you just arrived.
We just finished Monopoly.
We're currently playing with Hewn, Sykkuno, and Doki.
It's really good.
It's awesome.
So, um, yeah, man.
It's great.
And now we're gonna...
I'm down.
We'll have to chat.
Yeah, dude, let's do it.
Let's do it.
And I'll see you at TwitchCon as well.
It's going to be awesome.
Not really.
Currently, I've just been, like, vibing.
Um, so wait, you said we were doing Roblox, right?
Yeah, we're doing...
Yeah, yeah.
Roblox Party.
I'm DonkSass5000.
Wait, are we doing Roblox Party or are we doing Duels first?
I mean, whatever you guys want to do.
I don't...
I never played Roblox Party before, so I don't...
Dude, it's...
My idea.
We're gonna play Roblox.
Dude, yeah, we're gonna do it, bro.
Well, you said you only had an hour, so I didn't want to do something too time consuming.
I have a coaching session for Modern Zangief.
No, honestly, actually, I'm so down.
Who are you getting coached...
Who are you getting coached by?
I pulled in a ringer.
Not my usual coach, but I pulled in a ringer for Modern Zangief.
Justin?
No, no, no.
Bro.
This guy, uh...
Oh, my God.
I heard he's an EVO champion.
Bye, Anita.
I get things done for the ring.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, my God.
Dude, playing champ on the background, so...
But, dude, honestly, guys, so I decided to listen to Chaperone when I was in LA.
I've been in LA for the last, like, six months.
Six months or so?
I'm back in the UK now for a little bit.
I'm going back out for TwitchCon again.
Dude, so I listened to Chaperone when I was there, and I have been, like, straight up, like, legitimately addicted.
Like, dude, holy crap.
They are so freaking talented.
Like, dude, the whole album or, like, sorry, the whole, like, all of the songs so far, which I've listened to, have been fucking incredible, dude.
Modern Zangief has given me something so much, but honestly, they've been, like, actually straight up incredible as hell.
It's been so...
Dude, Chaperone goes crazy.
Goes actually crazy.
You idiot!
Um, Sebastian, thank you for the three dollars as well, man.
I appreciate the love, dude.
Thank you so much.
Um, yeah, actually fire, bro.
Actually fire as hell.
Wait, what's your...
What's your Roblox name?
Oh, wait, he has it in his title already?
Well, dude, I was gonna try and surprise people.
There you go.
I think...
I think you guys can join us.
Roblox!
Dude, I am so hyped for Roblox party.
I actually, weirdly, really enjoyed this last time.
Oh, wait, can I join?
It's a lot more faster paced.
How do I join you on this again?
You just click... click my link and then...
I'll click the link in general.
...and then you come over to the quad section and then you'll probably see my model.
Oh, I press play.
Oh, I press play and then I go...
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Ohhhh.
Alright, I'm in.
I got daily awards.
Let's go.
Do you see me?
Are you Thomas the Tank Engine?
Yeah, I'm Thomas the Tank Engine.
Dude, why would you...
Why?
Is that lore behind this?
No, why?
What?
Dude, I thought Thomas the Tank Engine was...
Who doesn't want to be a...
I like trains.
Dude, I'm being so real.
I thought Thomas the Tank Engine was a British thing.
I'm just gonna say it.
I thought it was a British thing.
Is it?
Apparently not though.
It's not?
You guys know Thomas the Tank Engine?
Yeah, is he not British?
Don't they talk in a British accent?
Is it not?
I swear, it's worldwide?
Dude, am I bugging out?
I swear, I thought it was like a British show.
I thought no one in America knew about it.
Okay, well, hey, there we go.
Now, now...
Wait, you thought no one knew about Thomas the Tank Engine?
No, dude.
Oh, so that's what you meant?
Oh, I thought you meant like...
Wait, you and I are in your game.
Oh yeah, I see you.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, you're here, you're here.
I see Doki as well.
I just don't...
Maybe I should change my skin.
You guys think I should change my skin?
It is...
I like the Iron Mouse skin.
Do you have the Iron Mouse one, too?
I got it when we were playing with Mouse.
It's like kind of like a meme, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Wait, you're Thomas the Tank Engine?
What is that?
I like trains.
Dude, it's crazy.
Dude, I should be...
It's crazy when you were saying I chose it as a meme and then Doki said you sat there looking like Thomas the fucking Tank Engine.
It's because I saw somebody with a car skin and I was like, oh my god, wait, did that exist?
Yeah, some of the skins are crazy.
Yeah, so I was like, I'm gonna be Thomas.
Wait, wait, where are you, Doki?
Oh, I'm here.
I'm here.
I'm literally the train.
Wait, what?
I don't see the train, dude.
Where the fuck is the train?
We're in the middle, we're in the middle.
I'm in the middle.
Wait, are you...
Did you click my link?
Are you in here?
I did, but it didn't put me into anything.
What?
It didn't put me into anything.
Am I friends with you on Roblox?
Oh.
We don't need to be friends.
You can just click the link.
Oh, wait, I think I'm joining, I think I'm joining.
I think I'm joining.
I think I pressed the wrong one.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, that's him.
That's him.
Yo, what's good?
Yo.
It's time, guys.
Dude, you're...
All right.
Let's go.
Hugh's hands and feet just made me die, bro.
Look at the size of those things.
Let's try a different map than last time, you think?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Huh?
Let's do it, let's do it, let's do it.
Which map, what?
Which map?
Never played this one before.
Just like, I don't...
Oh, Salzburg looks nice.
Let's do that, let's do that.
It's like a little Christmas looking town.
All right.
Oh, yeah, it looks good.
Let's go.
Let's do it, guys.
Dude, honestly, guys, Roblox Party actually goes crazy.
It actually goes crazy, dude.
It's such a...
It's such a coked-ass game, but it's so much fun.
It's fun, bro.
It's so good.
Yeah, it's like a really...
Like, genuinely, I don't know how to describe it.
But it's actually good, though, in like a weird way, plus...
I mean, it's good because it's entertaining, but it's not good because it's fair, balanced, or makes any sense, so...
No, okay, by the way, by the way, also, Doki, if you want to, and I'm going to say this, if you want to choose the mini-games, it's pay to win.
You can literally choose the levels we do it by paying real money.
Yeah, if you pay real-life money, you can choose the mini-games.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I got a 1, dude?
Wow, this game doesn't want me to win.
Dude, I spent 20 bucks.
I did it.
I did, like, chose every level.
Oh my god, a 1!
You got a 1?
I got a 1?
You got this first!
Let's go!
Dude, wow.
Nice.
Very good.
Let's make it go.
Very, very good.
Oh, so you get the crown, right?
Yeah.
It's 15 to get the crown.
What the fuck is this?
Custom dice.
Oh my god, this is Mario Party, but like...
Dude, you're a tank.
Thomas the Tank Engine is fucking fried, bro.
This is Mario Party, but poor.
No, it is.
Wow.
It actually is.
Dude.
It's a Big Ten.
Doki, so they basically steal most of the mini-games, either Mario Party or Fool Guys.
Like, there's literally Hexagon in this game.
Like, Hexagon is a literal game in this.
But it's actually good, though.
It's actually fire.
Yeah, because you don't have to give Nintendo money.
You can play it fast.
Oh, Fawzi!
Wait.
The crown's to the right if you go in no directions.
Go, go.
Shut the fuck up.
Oh, free item.
Come on.
Crown won!
Wow.
What?
Let's go, bro.
He just got a golden crown.
That doesn't make any sense.
Guys, can you buy crowns with real money?
Dude, imagine.
Imagine.
It's literally pay to win.
Like, quite literally at that point, pay to win.
Look at the shop real quick.
Yeah, let me just have a quick browse real fast.
Holy crap, dude.
Mini-games are worth a lot, too.
Oh, my God, dude.
All right.
What are these mini-games?
As long as it's not Red Light Green Light.
Dude, Red Light Green Light's good.
Is this like Squid Game?
Is it like that Red Light Green Light?
I assume it is.
Yeah, I'd have to assume it is.
Yeah, it has to be, right?
Wait, what do I do?
Guys, guys, there's green.
Is that red?
Where are you guys going?
Wait, that was orange.
Wait.
Which way am I going?
What are you doing?
I'm dead.
How did you guys die?
Because I got stopped on the red.
This door.
I died.
Wait, white zones aren't safe, bro?
Dude, of course they're not safe.
Dude, I thought white zone meant safe.
No, you idiot.
What do you mean?
No.
I don't know.
I'm so fucking stupid, bro.
What?
Don't get terrifying.
Okay, I thought white zone meant safe.
I barely, I barely made it off the start line.
I literally barely made off the start line.
That is so embarrassing.
Yeah.
I got free rewards.
I thought white zone meant safe.
I don't know why they put those in the game.
Oh my goodness bro.
I'll get the gems.
I don't know what they're for but I'll get the gems.
That is crazy bro.
Alright, roll time.
It doesn't matter because like he has a crown.
Hey Dokie, could you sing the Thomas the Tank Engine theme song?
I don't even remember.
It's been years.
How do you remember the Thomas the Tank Engine song?
I don't.
The only child show I remember is Bananas in Pyjamas.
Does anyone remember that?
Bananas in Pyjamas?
What the fuck is... is that the...
The Bananas in Pyjamas.
Is that the one where they're in the blue pyjamas?
Yes dude.
Bananas in Pyjamas.
Yeah, they're like two banana twins and they're in blue pyjamas.
Yeah, Bananas in Pyjamas are coming down the stairs.
You guys...
Um...
Guys...
I don't know that one.
Oh...
How much money do I need to buy a crown again?
It's 20, right?
I think it's 15 actually.
A two?
Oh, hey man.
Oh, nice.
Like, can you look at how much gold you have?
Big roll.
Six.
Great.
Very good.
I don't think he has enough, guys.
So you're calling me a broke boy is what you're saying?
Yes.
No, I stole your coins earlier.
You did?
Yeah.
Why would you do that to me?
Because you have a crown warp.
What is that?
It's taller than I tell you.
The player closest to the crown.
Minigame time.
Please give me... give me like a missile mayhem.
That sounds fun.
Oh, what's World Wonderland?
Yes.
Oh, okay.
Yo, I ask and I shall receive.
Dude, he's playing off stream or something.
How does he know these games?
What did it say?
Stream sniping.
Wait, this is so slow.
Like, who's going to die to that?
Okay, how do you know?
Thank you, Michael.
How do you know this game?
Because we said this last time that me and Huynh both died, okay?
So let's just...
Okay, well, actually...
Yeah, I don't know why you jumped on top of my block.
What do you... you're blaming it on me?
You're blaming it on me?
That's crazy.
No, I didn't...
Wait, how did I die?
Wait, why did he die?
He died.
You died?
Oh, my God.
Wait, dude.
It's getting kind of...
Holy, wait.
What the fuck?
It's getting kind of quick.
What is the hitbox?
Okay, I now know what the hitbox is like.
I thought...
Dude, it's getting kind of fast.
It's going for Huynh.
Yeah, get her.
Get her.
Yeah, yeah.
Zone in on her.
What the fuck is that?
I don't know.
My feet might be big, but they're not big enough to get in.
The hitbox is so crazy.
Bro, it has...
Why does it have a splash zone?
What in the name of box-ass games is this, bro?
That's how I got this show, dude.
What the fuck?
Okay.
The splash zone.
Why is there a splash zone?
Yeah, that's fucked.
Three.
All right, here I go.
Very good.
Oh, I got a crown warp as well.
You got a crown warp as well.
Ain't no way, brothers.
That's insane.
Oh my god.
Wait, where did Huynh go?
She didn't go for the crown?
Yeah, you didn't go for the crown, Huynh.
How?
Because I rolled on...
I rolled just enough to get the crown, and then...
Oh, didn't have the money yet?
I didn't have the money, yeah.
Oh.
Was it 20 or 15?
It's 15.
Please don't...
And I had, like, 11.
I don't want to land on it.
Oh, thank god.
All right.
Wait.
Onwards, onwards, onwards.
The cyclone could add on it.
Yeah.
Give me my coins.
All right.
You're the closest.
Wait, I have an item.
Dude, I don't need that.
I'm going to roll a 10.
Do you think you're going to roll a 10?
I will bet my...
Huge roll.
Wait, what did he get?
What did he get?
Rolled a 10 right there.
He's one away?
He's literally just there.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
I'm going to steal this crown from him, by the way.
This is like Mario Party where you have to land, get the exact number, right?
Give me a sensor spin.
A sensor spin.
Oh.
Spiral.
No.
No, man.
Christ.
I don't want to subscribe.
Dude, what is this one?
How do you play?
Wait, how do you...
Oh, oh.
I think you're supposed to...
Let me go in this corner.
It looks...
Oh, no.
You have to keep track of this platform.
And then you're supposed to run to it after it's done spinning.
Oh, okay.
What?
Dude, I'm going to...
Oh, my.
Oh, okay.
Dude, it's obviously this...
It's obviously this...
Dude, I think cycles are going to go there.
Guys, what the fuck, guys?
Cycles are going to go there, by the way.
You guys just followed where I went.
Does anyone mess this up?
It doesn't even seem possible to mess up.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is silly.
No, no, no, no.
This is super simple.
You literally just walked where I walked, dude.
Dude, my eyes.
My eyes.
What?
It rubber banded.
Is it this one?
Is it this?
Dude, it literally rubber banded.
That is crazy.
This game is actually unloosable.
Dude, someone will have to jab me in the eyeball for me to lose this game.
Like, it's not even possible.
Dude, my thing is...
It's not even that fast.
Oh, wait a minute.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Just wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This one?
This is one of his.
It's not that.
No, wait.
What?
I almost got Sykkuno to die, though.
Oh, dude.
Dude, Doki tried to bait me.
Elem didn't even choose one.
Bro.
Dude, Elem didn't even choose one.
What is it?
There was literally a countdown.
Why is it brother, brother?
That's funny.
Everyone is one except for Elem.
I almost baited Sykkuno to die.
That's crazy, bro!
That was close.
That's funny.
Okay, as long as Doki rolls low here...
Oh my god.
Fuck you.
Holy crap.
Okay, okay.
There is no way, bro.
I get the first card.
I got the first crown.
I got the first crown here.
Wait, is he right in front of it?
No!
Yeah, he's literally right in front of it.
If you roll higher than a seven, you get it.
Real shame, Psychuno.
You just rolled a seven, you psychopath.
I'm doing this just to piss you off.
You could've just rolled a seven.
Give me my coin.
Give me my crown.
Yes.
That's mine.
That's insane.
Are we facing different?
We're going head-on.
Wait, how are we going head-on?
That makes no sense at all.
Wait a second.
Wait, how can you go that direction?
Where am I going?
Why have I gone in reverse?
Wait.
Dude, you're going in reverse.
Why am I going in reverse?
Dude, this game's broken.
Dude, this game's actually broken.
What?
Why am I going in reverse?
Dude, if he gets another golden coin...
Yo, value coins!
Receive a coin for every space you reach.
That's psychotic.
Who balanced this game, dude?
I'm going in reverse as well.
This is dope as fuck, bro.
You got warp tips to go in reverse.
Warped.
Bop.
Now, I'm further away from the star.
Just a little.
Very good.
Keep going, brother.
Keep going.
Where is it?
Where is it anyway?
Don't you do it.
No, you dick!
Oh my god.
There's no way you actually reached that.
There's actually no way.
I don't know how that makes any sense.
It doesn't seem...
There ain't no way you genuinely reached that, bro.
It doesn't seem right.
No, because it's not.
It's a load of BX, bro.
That's what I'm saying it is.
The crown's over there.
I'm not upset about it.
I'm just confused.
I am!
Someone's a little salty there.
I don't really know what happened.
Give me a blow the fuse.
Blow the fuse is so much fun.
Blow the fuse.
Come on.
What the fuck is stove survival?
What do you do for this one?
I'm just confused as to how I am going backwards now.
Wait, what are we doing?
Dude, how do you die in this one?
Surely there's literally no way you die.
I'm assuming it'll get harder, but as of right now...
I mean, it's for kids, man.
Guys, guys, guys.
We'll be fine, right?
Surely, right?
Yeah, we'll be fine.
Help me.
What?
Dude, dude.
That was every single one.
How did Alan win?
Dude, I jumped.
He jumped at the last second, but still died.
Every single one turned red.
That doesn't even make sense.
That is actually bullshit.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that was a thing.
Yeah, that happens.
That is fucking wild, bro.
Both sides go to the crown.
What's that money block?
I'll go this way.
Holy shit, that was funny.
Dude, I can't believe I jumped at the exact right time.
That's insane.
Dude, that is insane.
No, I don't have enough.
Holy crap.
Oh, it does.
You can buy it reverse.
Wait, you can buy it?
Oh, so you can pay to go back yourself?
Yeah, you can pay.
Oh, so the crown will...
Oh, okay.
That's a win.
Oh, return.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, there's a shop in this?
I don't think anyone's ever reached the shop before.
Yeah, the biggest thing is spending that much money is crazy.
What the frick?
Yeah, because you might as well just buy a crown.
Yeah.
Oh, that's huge.
Where's the other wall?
I don't know if that's close.
Oh, she's right next to it.
Wait, she's right in front of it.
No way.
Use my bag of coins.
For what reason?
The higher you roll now, the more coins you get.
I need money.
Ten coins, baby.
Wait, if you go to the right, you go on the teleporter.
You could be close.
Come on, come on, come on.
Huge gameplay.
Now you're right.
Where are you?
Never mind, guys.
That's unfortunate.
Oh, yeah, random bonus.
Make a rival lose five coins, please.
No, no!
If he chooses me, I'm gonna lose my mind.
It's doki, it's doki, it's doki.
It's just random.
Okay, here we go.
It was not random.
It was random.
It was 100% random.
Give me a boost to dodge.
Boost to dodge.
I like stove survival.
It was good.
It was a good time.
For everyone involved.
What do we do in this game?
I'm assuming you don't touch the blue.
Wait, what does that mean?
You collect the shells.
How do we get up?
I'm assuming you don't touch the blue.
Okay.
Wait.
This is chalks, bro.
Do you like...
Do you like lose if you don't...
If you die in the water?
No, no, no.
You get sent back.
I think you're just trying to collect as many shells as possible.
It just resets you, basically.
So there's no penalty for touching the water?
There's literally none.
You just gotta like...
Dude...
I have like zero shells, though.
No, there is a penalty.
There is a penalty.
There is?
Yeah, there is!
Why do you all have zero?
I see Sykuna with 13 shells.
You're like zero there.
Sykuna never touched the water.
How many do I have?
I've got zero.
I've invaded all of you.
Sykuna invaded all of you guys and himself.
There's no way.
You lose all of them when you die, I guess.
There's actually no way I get zero, though.
There's actually no way I get zero.
You actually invaded yourself.
It's because you kept dying saying, no, there's no penalty for touching the water.
There is actually no way.
There is no shot, dude.
That's actually fucking hilarious.
Oh my god, bro.
The fact that he was actually ignorant.
The worst thing to do is I actually thought, I thought I was cooking that as well.
I thought I was absolutely cooking.
That's right in front of me.
That might be right behind me.
That's right behind you.
You gotta get another one.
Give me something big.
A four.
You got three coins, though.
That does nothing for me.
Dude, it's right behind me.
I can't believe it.
You gotta buy the reverse.
Would you like to view the shop?
How much money I got here?
You have enough to buy the reversal.
Dude, golden block.
Wait a minute.
If I buy the reverse, though.
No, I'm about to go eight, though.
I think I just go golden block here.
I'm about to move eight forward.
So I'd have to reverse eight.
Hit him with the reversal, bro.
You can still do it.
Yeah, you can still do it.
You're still there.
I still believe, you know.
Why can't I click this?
Welcome to Roblox.
Looks like you're teleporting now, bro.
Looks like you're teleporting.
Very good.
Very, very good.
Oh, no.
Mini-game time.
Okay, could've been worse.
Dude, that was Taco Tuesday.
Kinda hope we get it.
Oh, dang.
Nice.
Dude, it looks like Play-Doh.
Yeah, it kinda does.
Wait, it is like Play-Doh.
Why is there, like, no instructions?
Like...
Dude, what?
Oh, you gotta, like, make the tacos.
Okay.
Who's on my team?
Who's on my team right now?
I don't think this is a team game.
I don't...
Dude, this game is garbage.
This is not a game.
There's no skill involved.
Hold one button, dude.
This is not a game.
Dude, Hyuna is like a well-woven machine at this, bro.
This is a real game.
It's just not a real game.
Hyuna!
I'm going, I'm going.
This is not a real game.
That was a 2v2 game.
Yeah, it was a team effort.
Oh, my god.
They say we're playing undercooked.
Bro, that's crazy.
Oh, my god.
Jesus Christ.
Give me that crown.
Oh, my god.
I want to have a crown, too.
Doki, no.
All of us had crowns.
I want to be special, too.
No, you're not allowed.
You're forbidden.
Spawn near me for once in my life.
For once in my life.
Yay!
Nice.
Spawn next to me.
No!
This is bad.
It's kind of near me, I guess.
Why are they just not going anywhere other than me, bro?
It's like it's probably avoiding my ass.
It's not too far away.
Please.
Alright, a bonus.
It's winnable.
Dash block?
What's that?
It's like a mushroom.
Oh, that's kind of good, though.
Yeah, it's super good.
Let's go.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
It's Donka's turn.
Donka's.
Oh, wait.
Donka's can do this.
Oh, Donka's can do this.
She's warping.
I bought it from the shop.
And she's got 16 coins.
Why does my shop have a crown warp?
That doesn't seem right.
Yeah, why does it not have one?
Your shop's poor.
Oh, wait.
You bought that?
Yeah, now she's first.
Now I have one coin.
Yo, she's juiced.
She needs one more crown and she wins.
She's juiced, bro.
Donka's...
Donka's donking right now.
Holy Christ.
Wait, Sykkuno's close to the second one.
Am I?
Yeah, it's literally at the bottom left.
Dude, I'm facing the opposite direction.
Please, for the love of God, let me in the big room.
I think I'm going the opposite direction.
Come on!
Go!
Go, Shrek!
He's almost there!
He's gonna win!
Go up that ladder, dude.
Is the ladder up there better?
Oh, no.
I don't know actually.
You lose a turn.
No!
Get to the shop!
Use!
No, it's not!
That's not part of the pathway.
After the shop, he loses a turn.
No!
Sykkuno!
You screwed me again!
To be fair, I didn't know that would happen.
I genuinely didn't know.
Gold and dice attack!
Oh, God.
And then, big roll up.
Big roll up.
I thought you were backwards.
Ten!
Thirty coins for a crown?
Dude, since when did it cost thirty coins for a crown?
Dude, why is it so expensive?
Dude, what's happening?
What am I doing?
I thought coins were only fifteen.
You stole my crown, you dick!
Oh, my God, dude.
No wonder it's thirty coins for a crown.
There is no way you jack mine.
No wonder.
Oh, my God.
It makes so much sense.
I've got nothing.
I was like, why is it charging me thirty coins for a crown?
This is like Monopoly all over again.
This is Monopoly all over again.
Wait, what do you mean?
You won Monopoly?
Barely.
You're saying you're going to win this one too?
The reverse sweep.
He's doubling down.
Wait, Sykkuno wins this minigame?
He wins.
Obstacle dash.
Dude, and I'm an obstacle dasher.
I'm an obstacle dash expert, you could say.
Here we go.
Oh, it's parkour time.
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait, what the heck?
I'm dead, bro.
This is cooked, bro.
What?
How do you play this?
That's what I'm saying.
Dude, what is this game, dude?
I think you have to avoid the glowing stuff.
Why do they have no explanation for any of these games?
Who invented this and was like, I'm not going to tell you how to play anything and you just die.
Dude, it just...
I go...
The timing of that was so off.
It was so weird.
That was so strange, bro.
They didn't tell us a single dang thing.
They didn't tell you how to play.
I literally don't get it.
Dude, I'm pivoting to modern Shrek after if I lose this to Elem.
You're pivoting to modern Shrek?
I'm pivoting to modern Shrek after.
I need some new fucking ground.
Holy shit, dude.
I need to find this.
What do you mean?
I can reverse sweep.
Wait a minute.
Wait a second.
Why are you jockeying me with my money?
Dude.
Yuna.
Nice job, Yuna.
It only takes like five.
Five coins.
Only five shekels.
And I lose a ton.
I'm poor.
I had one.
I lost the crown.
I lost my money all in one turn.
That makes that is crazy.
That is crazy.
Saikudo might actually get the crown and win.
There's no way.
He gets a double dice?
Seven.
He actually wins.
I don't have enough money.
I stole the crown from Elem.
Holy crap, bro.
Oh my god.
There's actually no way.
Does anyone else get to play this game?
Hany avoided the double freeze as well.
It's crazy.
You're losing your three coins.
I just need to win this minigame, right?
Yeah, you just need to win a minigame.
And you win.
Just give us obstacle dash again.
Run it back.
We learned how to play borders.
It's a team game.
Can we get some instructions for once?
Saikudo's team just needs to throw.
Is that too much to ask for?
What are we doing?
Wait, do we grab stuff?
Wait.
Am I trying to get it red or am I trying to get it blue?
You're trying to get it blue.
Dude, I just inted myself.
You're trying to get it to blue.
Get in blue.
The golden ball.
Get in blue quick.
To blue.
I'm supposed to get it to red.
You guys are idiots.
You guys are actually idiots.
Dude, I scored on ourselves.
I'm saying Saikudo wins in your last place.
Yeah, honestly.
Wait a second.
Int it.
Turn it on.
Dude, Ellen, we've got to win this, man.
You need the tokens, though, too.
Int.
You have to win this.
Ellen, we've got to win this, man.
Int.
Ellen, we've got to win this, dude.
Dude, you're going to get coins.
You're going to get coins, bro.
Guys, get them in.
Guys, I'm blocking them.
Guys, you've got to get them in.
Guys, one more.
Guys, please.
Yes.
He goalied you.
Dude, he actually inted you, psychopath.
Why?
That's so funny.
Dude, now Huun's going to win.
You've thrown the game, you fool.
You've thrown the game.
Oh, my God.
Dude, Huun wins now.
She's right by the crown.
She's not.
She's really right by the crown.
You've handed her the win.
You've handed her the win, you fool.
I've been 3v1'd again.
How is it possible?
Getting 3v1'd in every game.
There is no way.
You're just too powerful.
Oh, God.
There's actually no fucking way.
She literally wins now, Ellen.
Unless if I roll a 1.
I can't believe it.
I've been 3v1'd again.
Why didn't you tell me?
I've been 3v1'd.
I feel like that's the conscious decision you made, man.
That's the conscious decision you made.
That's not even a secret thing.
Why wouldn't you just tell me?
Your alliance is just not there.
Your alliance is just so fragile.
Pathetic.
Run it back.
What happened to this alliance?
Is there no time to?
I mean...
Run it back.
This is a fast game.
It is a fast game.
Oh, yeah.
I can't believe he did that.
Dude, I can't believe he did that.
That's it.
I didn't know.
You didn't tell me.
I was trying to make the game go on longer.
And you, sir, didn't say.
I didn't tell you that if you inted, someone else would win.
I didn't think I had to.
I didn't think that was a thing I had to describe.
I didn't know if Huun won, she would've won the whole thing.
I'm going to Atlantis.
You bumbling fool.
I'm coming to Atlantis.
Are you guys still in the lobby?
You threw the game, man.
Communicate with me.
You bumbling fool.
How do I have to tell you throwing the game would result in you throwing the game?
That's so obvious.
On what planet?
I'm going to Atlantis.
I've already been in Atlantis.
I've already been here, so this is my place now.
Oh, God.
Okay, as long as I don't last this time, it'll be fine.
As long as I don't get lost, then yeah.
I don't want to get fourth again.
You know what I mean?
Here we go.
You didn't get fourth, you got second.
What do you mean?
I got fourth.
I mean, second is the first to lose.
That's a good house to go, dude.
Oh, God.
Okay, here we go.
Big roll, big roll.
What'd I get?
A seven?
A three?
I won!
The world does not want me to win.
It's decided I'm a loser.
But you know what?
I can turn that around by locking in Modern Zangief.
That'll make me a winner.
That's the day.
Tomorrow you're gonna win.
Holy Christ.
Alright, this way.
Oh, hey, I get to go further ahead and lose.
No, I don't.
Jesus.
Okay.
Lock it in.
No, I'm rolling.
Bam, bam, ba-ba-bam.
Chat, we're vibing.
He's not the protagonist, dude.
It's crazy.
I mean, I'm already going to the crown.
I can't take it anymore.
Holy shit, dude.
What an interesting map.
It's kinda weird.
What, your binds are in the shop?
There's no way anyone's got money.
A bag of coins.
You can buy a bag of coins?
That doesn't make any sense.
How much was a bag of coins?
I assume five coins is all she had.
But that means you can just make money back on it.
Yeah.
It doesn't make any sense.
Okay, alright.
And then you get three as well.
Wait, that is so broken.
Big roll me, big roll me.
A three.
A classic three.
Big money, big money.
Come on now.
But I get to roll again thanks to my special ability.
Dimension the dice.
But you can't buy anything.
You blundering fool.
And then, dimension the dice.
I roll again.
Wait, how is he still a ten?
Wait, how did you have so much dice?
How far away am I from this?
How is he doing this?
Wait, how do you have so much dice?
He was doing dimension the dice.
Where am I going right now?
Did you pay for this?
Yeah, I just want to let you guys know I could have bought it if I had money.
Did you like buy more dice to play?
No, he's just gone.
I'm going down.
I'm going solid snack mode.
Why am I climbing back up?
That doesn't make sense.
What?
Dude, what is happening in this game?
Why are you going up and jumping on buffers, dude?
What is happening?
Wait, he can steal coins.
He's stealing coins.
Well, I can't steal from him.
Are you joking me?
You steal from me again?
What happened to the alliance?
What are you doing?
I can't steal from Dote.
Dude, you threw last game for someone else to win.
You didn't communicate with me.
If you communicated, we would have been fine.
If you throw the game, you're going to throw the game.
You're an idiot.
I feel like it was so obvious.
I didn't think I had to say, if you throw this game, it'll be thrown.
I just felt like that was an obvious.
I didn't think that required it.
You shouldn't assume.
What is this?
Tickling time bomb?
What's that?
Surely they'll explain something.
Yeah, surely we'll understand, right?
Pass the bomb to another player.
How do I pass it?
You dick!
Why did you target me, you asshole?
You're literally right next to me.
Wait, I didn't click on him.
Oh no.
You have to click?
You have to click it?
I guess you do.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Yes!
You!
Nobody can stop Iron Mouse.
There is no way, bro.
There is no way, dude.
Big gameplay.
The wall isn't even real.
Yeah, the wall's not real.
I was like, can I glitch this through the wall?
Holy shit, dude.
I was like, what the fuck?
You passed it to me?
Where do I go?
I slipped it around the wall.
Wait, I gotta play it.
Wait.
Oh, I wish I could use it.
That's what I'm thinking.
That's what I was thinking, but now I can't do it.
Onwards.
Wait, am I facing the wrong way now?
Yeah, you are.
Yes!
You got your two more!
I'm not even gonna buy it.
Dude, this is just ridiculous.
I don't think anybody can buy it right now.
No shot, dude.
There is no a way.
There ain't no a way.
Oh my god.
Except I'm facing the wrong way.
Yeah, you're facing the wrong way.
Jesus.
You going, bro?
Wait, Hyun might be able to...
Dude, if she uses her coin pouch, yeah, this is where the money comes out.
That's kinda juiced.
If she gets a high roll here, that could be the game changer.
A nine!
Wait, she can buy it, maybe.
Wait, she actually can buy it if she makes it.
Can you make it?
Do you make it is the question.
Do you make it to it?
Oh, she does.
Yeah, she does.
Is this another Hyun win?
Dude, Hyun's gonna win again.
Dude, no way, no way, no way.
Dude, she's too powerful, bro.
I'm too poor, I'm too poor.
Wait, you are?
Oh, you were two coins away.
God dang.
I got a lot of money, though.
You were actually two coins.
Okay.
Too bad you're facing the wrong way.
What item do I even have?
Oh, I got one of these?
Big roll, big roll me.
Okay, okay, okay.
One, one, one, one.
Six.
Six is good, it's a classic.
Let's go for the spicy option here.
What's that?
Oh, he's gonna do the...
He's gonna do the reverse, though.
You're doing the reverse round, right?
Yeah, she did.
What button?
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
I don't even know what I'm doing, bro.
The coins are switched between you and...
I can't see.
Thank you.
No way.
Dude, there was no icons on the dice.
Wow.
How was I supposed to play the game?
There's no icons on the dice.
I didn't even see what happened.
Because the icons on the dice were flipped around.
This game is actually garbage.
Dude, dude.
Dude, my chat saw...
Guys, there were no icons on the dice.
How was I supposed to play that?
There was no icons.
There were no icons.
They were flipped backwards.
It doesn't even make sense.
Bro, that's actually insane.
You should have flipped it back.
What the frick?
Dude, the icons were flipped backwards on the dice.
It's crazy.
Wait, what the frick is this thing?
Wait, but how do you tell which one it is?
Yeah.
What?
Oh, it's on the poles.
Okay, I didn't notice that until later.
What the frick is this thing?
That's so dumb.
Yeah, listen.
No matter what bad luck happens, the minigame winner wins.
That's so dumb.
The minigame winner keeps on winning.
I couldn't tell how the colors were.
I thought about telling you.
Then I realized I needed that win after losing.
Boom.
Give me that sweet nine.
Now watch him climb down and then climb back up.
Wait, why does he climb back up?
I don't know.
Wait a second.
I can steal stuff.
Dude, this counts as one space.
Well, well, well.
Looks like I'm going to be...
Elm, if you want the alliance to be back on, hit random.
What?
This is your chance to make everything better.
You costed me last game.
Wait, I didn't choose it.
Why did you choose me, you psycho?
You already threw my last game.
Don't think I'll remember this one.
I didn't choose.
I swear I didn't choose.
No, I swear I didn't.
No, I didn't even click anything.
No, I swear.
Oh, free agent.
I swear.
I didn't even click anything.
That was great.
It just randomly chose you.
I don't know about you guys, but this alliance looks mighty.
Dude, you're Thomas the Tank Engine.
He looks like he's going through something.
There ain't no way.
Dude, that does not look good.
This alliance is very shaky.
Holy shit.
He keeps stealing.
He threw the game last round.
He's just making everything go down the middle.
I don't know, dude.
It randomly...
What?
You already stole my coins because my flipping thing was backwards.
I didn't steal your coins.
You lost it yourself.
What do you mean?
It was flipped backwards.
It was actually flipped backwards.
They were blank.
Like the dice were blank for me.
And I just kept hitting space bars.
Holy shit, dude.
Almost as cook...
Dude, Hyun's hands and feet keep getting bigger, I swear.
You think so?
Dude, she's going to start growing extra fingers next time we see her.
Holy crap.
Look at me, man.
The way those feet move down the rope.
They're so cut.
Is there like a cosmetic where it makes your head into a hand or a foot?
What?
I feel like there probably would be.
There's got to be.
Roblox has like a crazy stuff.
You will be the lucky one today.
For fuck's sake.
Hey, thanks, dude.
You're a real one.
I mean, she just chose randomly, Elm.
She chose randomly.
Yeah, Elm chose randomly.
Of course, of course, of course.
She used to be upset over random.
Yes, I could've.
I chose random as well.
Well, Elm targeted me.
It randomly selected you, bro.
Mine was random.
It was random.
Bop a two, exactly what I wanted.
A little three-sie, a little three-sie.
Okay, okay.
That has still not been taken yet.
That's actually crazy.
What do you got there?
Give us obstacle notes.
Pizza press, pizza press, pizza press.
Oh, what the frick is this?
Will they ever tell us how to play the games?
No.
Probably not.
It says ready, and then you just...
Avoid the snowballs.
Dude.
Where am I?
I'm sliding away.
Wait, I gotta take Sykkuno's technique.
Sykkuno's technique at the bottom.
I have to stay at the bottom.
Mathematically proven that if you stand in this corner that...
Wait, dude, I'm cheating.
Wait, there's two?
There's two now.
There's two.
No.
Oh, god.
Don't push me, bro.
Don't push me.
You pushed me.
No, yes.
Yes, yes.
Doki, die.
Doki.
Doki, you better win.
Doki, no.
Doki, yes.
Why are we getting all the bottom?
Because I made up a rumor that it's mathematically proven that going to the bottom is safer.
And I've won most of the time in the Mario Party version.
Holy crap, dude.
Yeah, yeah, but in the Roblox version, it's the opposite.
It's the other way around.
Holy Christ.
Dude, Elm, you're only seven away from the star.
Thank god for that.
Yeah, you can roll a seven.
Yeah, yeah, you have an inventory.
Boom.
No.
That's money, though.
That's money.
I mean, that's money.
Yeah, that's money, yeah.
You did just need a seven, though.
What's up?
What are you trying to do?
You went the wrong way.
Why'd you go that way?
Wait, this is the wrong way.
Am I being...
Yes.
Yes, the crown.
Thank god for that.
As long as she doesn't roll an eight, I'm chilling.
Oh, it looks like the clam come back later.
Oh, boy.
As long as I roll high enough, I get this.
It'll be funny if you get a two.
What do I need, like a five?
You need, like, a three.
Oh, dude, if I get less than a three, I may as well ult that four now.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
No way, dude.
Oh, my god.
There ain't no way.
There ain't no shot, dude.
Beautiful.
There ain't no way.
If I wasn't last pick, that would've been the W right there.
Oh, my god.
Wait, this is kind of close.
This is kind of close.
That's crazy.
That's actually the unlucky.
Dude, the bad luck.
The bad luck.
The bad luck doesn't...
At least it's happening today instead of tomorrow.
The five coins.
I'm already, like, second to the bottom seed.
No way.
I wouldn't have made it anyway.
This is insanity.
You always made it.
Holy shit.
There ain't no shot, bro.
There actually ain't no way.
This is the worst luck ever.
Hole in the wall.
Come on.
Give us a hole in the wall.
Please.
How would I...
Not Taco Tuesday again.
Ever since you mentioned it.
Dude, this one sucks.
This one sucks.
This is not a game.
Where am I?
This one's literally not a game.
I couldn't figure out...
You bopped me.
Lock it in.
Wait, you can bop each other?
I think so.
Dude, I'm using my two-hand technique.
What the fuck does that mean?
He's making...
Another hand for E.
Yeah.
Bro's min-maxing.
This is crazy.
He needs to win.
Look at my speed, though.
Look at that speed, though.
You laugh at the technique, but it's so good, though.
But we're almost tied.
We're tied.
No, that means we all lose.
Once again.
You know in Mario Party, when you all tie, everyone wins?
In this one, everyone loses.
Does no one...
Yeah, it just doesn't matter, bro.
What happened to the two-hand technique?
I mean, it is...
Honestly, there's only so much you can do.
Well, guys, I guess I gotta do this.
Are we taking my crown now?
Thank you so much.
I'm on the way.
Very good.
This map is small, actually, now that I look at it.
Give me my crown, please, for the love of God.
Roll.
He might win this game.
He might.
Bang.
A classic four.
I thought that one crown was zero mini-game wins.
Yes.
That is true.
And we're so back.
We are so back right now.
Someone steal his crown.
No.
You're sick.
Wait, it's in front of me.
It's in front of me.
No way.
It's right in front of Hewn again.
Wait, really?
It's in front of all of us.
Dude, this is crazy.
Guess who's in fourth place for rolls.
There's no way I get this.
Galaxy, I get this.
Wait, he's gonna use his dash block?
No, he's not.
No, I can't.
I can't.
Wait, Doki gets this right now.
Yeah, I get this.
Yeah.
No, Doki, why?
I have the most mini-games win.
It doesn't matter.
Well, maybe it'll spawn in front of me.
Yeah, yeah.
It could spawn in front of you.
What are the odds?
Like, it's gonna spawn in front of me.
There it is.
Right in front of nobody.
No, there it is.
Oh, that's great.
No, that's great.
Oh, it's so far.
Oh, god.
I mean, it's... Oh, wait.
Wait, so do you have a crown?
You have nothing.
All I have is the mini...
Wait, I don't know.
I'm going back up.
Wait, how do I...
You suck on the rope?
What the...
What the fuck happened?
This is cucked.
This is actually cucked.
I blinked for a second.
It's actually cucked, bro.
Dude, she's hacking.
And she rolls again.
Wait, Doki, I swear to god.
Wait, she can steal a star.
Dude, she can steal a crown.
Oh my god, she didn't.
She didn't.
Dude, no way she steals a crown though, right?
Doki!
Yeah, yeah.
That's the move.
Now Elem has no money.
No crowns.
No nothing.
Wait, you have two crowns?
How the heck in the heck?
Dude, Elem, that's so sad.
Dude, that was my first fucking crown.
Okay, as long as I don't get last, I'm chilling.
As long as I don't get last, I'm chilling.
Is that a golden?
That wasn't a golden.
No, that's not.
If it was, I would have used it.
Dude, if that's a golden teleporter, it's GG.
Oh, Jesus Christ!
I got the money though, unless I win the minigame.
Technically, Sekiro could steal the crown as well.
I don't plan on it, I don't plan on it.
I mean...
Well, I don't have the money, do I?
You just need...
Hewn, you wouldn't, right?
Oh, wait, look at what I can do.
Wait, if you steal money from Sykkuno, he can't afford to steal a crown.
I'm pressing random, I'm pressing random.
No, show your pressing random right there!
No, I swear!
I swear!
I swear on my life, it was random.
Remember that.
This is how you've been repaid.
That's actually crazy!
Dude, and she just lost the coins you just paid for her.
Oh, thank you.
It's a net...
Back of coins!
Hey, you got your coins!
You can afford the crown.
Okay, we got a few coins.
Dude, I ain't going for a steal.
I'm going for the crown.
I think Doki's about to win though, like a crown or a couple minigames.
No, I need like two, I need like three minigames.
Yeah, three minigames maybe, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe two, I don't know.
Wait, Blackout, wait.
Are they going to explain how to play this game?
There's gonna be like text at the very top.
It's that crab game where you gotta like run, and you gotta like get the cubes.
So whoever red and blue is, we gotta get them.
Oh, all of it?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I see now.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna follow.
This game is dankest, man.
This is like that Fall Guys game.
This game is kind of nice though.
This is that Fall Guys game.
Oh, the music's kind of picking up though.
Don't even lie, the music's kind of picking it up a little bit.
Dude!
Nice try, LM.
I see what you're doing.
Dude, the music is picking up a little bit.
Stop!
Give me back my squares.
Give these back to me.
I got a strat going on.
Hold up.
Wait a second, she's dialed in.
Oh my god, wait, I don't even know who's on my team.
Bro, it's unfair to you, she's got large feet.
She's got more surface area.
This is ridiculous.
Her feet!
Her feet are too cracked.
It makes no sense.
Who won?
We crushed it.
Dude, who was my partner?
They got like nothing.
Dude, I was going, I was going.
What happened?
I was going, trust me.
I had so many.
I had a lot too, but LM was just following me.
I was following Doki and then LM started following me.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm sorry.
Now LM's going to win.
We gotta gang up on him again.
No matter how many games LM's gonna win, or will win, he will never win.
He'll never get a crown.
I will.
I'm gonna get a crown.
Wait, you didn't go for the crown?
That's actually crazy that you didn't.
No, I thought I was gonna get a crown warp.
I thought I was gonna get a crown warp.
I was praying for that, but it didn't work, bro.
It didn't work.
That's so fucked.
Bro.
No matter what's gonna happen, he was never gonna get a crown.
This is so stupid.
Dude, how is anyone going to beat Doki in this situation?
That's what I'm saying, bro.
He's too cracked.
Wait, am I actually right by the crown?
You're literally right by the crown.
I think you need to roll like a seven or something.
He's too cracked.
Dude, how did we lose so badly last game?
It was like 59.
That's what I'm saying.
What did we do wrong?
Because you guys forgot that there were squares at the top, too.
I went for a few of those, bro.
Yeah, I went for...
Nobody took the top squares.
So my top squares were...
Wait, why aren't you going for the crown?
Oh, wait.
You can warp Doki out right now.
Wait, is Doki about to...
Yeah, they're gonna win if you don't.
Doki, Doki, Doki.
You're gonna warp me?
No, you should warp to Sakuro.
He's even closer than me.
He's even closer.
See?
He's really close.
Please tell him you warp me and we lose.
You warp me and we lose, man.
You know this to be true.
What are you gonna do?
What are you gonna buy?
You bought a crown warp?
Yeah, why not?
That worries me, man.
It worries me.
All I'm saying is if you warp him, he'll be forced to use his crown warp.
Shit.
I actually timed this perfectly.
Oh, he gazed it!
Because I get one coin every time I move, and I was able to buy it and the crown warp.
He just got it, yeah.
Dude, that's insane.
I made it to the crown, plus I got one coin every roll, which means...
He can...
Wait, dude, who's that next to?
Who's that next to?
Wait, is that Doki?
It's near Doki.
Yeah, no, I don't...
I can't get there.
No way, it's near me.
Dude, what?
The crown moves what a...
Wait, receive one thousand coins.
You just lost ten coins, dude.
You're one coin, oh my god.
You're one coin.
Give us a new one.
Give us a juicy one.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
This one, this one's dumb.
Here we go, guys.
Give me what I need.
Give me what I need here.
Oh yeah.
Oh god, I almost stepped on the...
Stop pushing me.
I think it still kills you like that.
Sykes, you're pushing me.
Syke, you killed me.
I'm not even there.
What was he yelling out?
Syke.
I literally did not...
Use your large hands and push me.
Push me under the stove.
What do you mean?
I'm sorry, what can I do?
I was born with these feet.
She actually killed me.
I landed on her head.
And then she pushed me.
She's gonna win, guys.
Guys, she's literally about to win.
I didn't do anything.
You jumped on my head.
What was I supposed to do?
Bro, where is the crown?
Oh my god, dude.
That's crazy.
What is this thing?
It's on the other side.
Is it five away?
Yeah, you're five away.
Here we go, here we go.
Come on, please.
Five to an eight.
Oh, thank Christ.
I think he gets it.
Oh my god, thank Christ.
Boom.
Yes, finally I get a crown.
Finally I get a crown.
Oh my god, hallelujah.
There it is.
That's what I always needed.
Just one more crown to add to my collection.
Oh my lord, yes, yes.
Okay, well this game could go to anybody if you take Doki out of the picture.
What did I just do?
That's true.
Or well, you're just so far ahead.
I loop back around again.
I loop around again.
I mean, they have no coins.
Yeah, I'm broke as hell.
I have three coins right now.
Wait, Doki's almost to the next crown.
She's 18 away.
I literally have three freaking coins right now.
Let's see.
Oh, there's no gold crown.
Oh, is it because I bought it?
Yeah, you bought it.
Yeah, only the first person who goes can buy it.
Not close.
I'm almost there.
Keep going.
Wait, how close is the shop?
Wait, you could buy a crown.
Dude, you're so rich.
There's no crown.
No, I'll buy this though.
That's only five dollars.
Wait, what's a golden block?
Is that like the dash block?
Yeah, more numbers.
Oh.
Alright, plus three.
Okay, okay.
But Sykkuno has the crown warp.
He does?
Oh yeah, you have the money.
Yeah.
Cute.
Where's my item though?
You have the...
Wait, what did you have?
No, I just had a custom dash block.
Oh, okay.
And you go to the shop as well.
That's huge.
Is there a crown there?
There's a crown warp.
Oh my god.
You could buy that and get a crown.
This one would be more fun.
There's a player warp as well, man.
Okay, okay.
What was that sound?
Good luck, guys.
Receive a crown.
What the?
How is that a thing in this game?
That doesn't make any sense.
Like, how is that a thing in this game?
Oh my god.
Where's the skill?
This is a Roblox Mario Party.
What do you mean by skill?
Dude, even Mario parties are full of stuff like that.
That is absolutely cooked, bro.
Dude, Mario Party doesn't even pull stuff like that.
That's crazy.
Holy crap, bro.
That's actually insane.
That is insane.
Is Yoon gonna get the two free?
The two wins in a row?
Surely not, right?
She's the goat.
She's the goat of Roblox party.
The two for two.
Two for two.
What the fuck is cheese cheese?
Give me a hole in the wall.
I guess we're gonna find out.
Another game we don't know.
It looks kinda cute though.
I'm assuming you gotta go through and not fall through the holes.
Yeah, oh.
Oh yeah, dude, that's easy.
Oh, you're just running through.
Dude, how do you die in this?
You don't.
Maybe if your feet are too big?
That's how Ellen loses it.
Dude ran it down her wrist.
Yeah.
He had so much time.
I thought you had to jump up.
I thought there was a finish line.
I thought there was a finish line, bro.
What the frick?
Why did you go through the hole?
Wait, we all win.
Do we all win?
Wait, doesn't that mean Doki just wins?
Yeah, Doki wins.
Doki just wins?
Dude, how are we gonna stop her in that game?
I don't know.
She's too strong.
She's too strong, bro.
Let's go.
Get ready for my coaching session.
Alright, good luck with your coaching session.
See you guys later.
Peace to the games, guys.
GG's, everybody.
Bye.
Oh my gosh.
That was fun, dude.
That was actually really fun.
Honestly, god, I'm gonna be surreal.
Roblox is just a good game.
I don't wanna be the day where I genuinely mean that and actually say it.
But like...
I actually really fuck with that game.
Like, it's really... dude, it's good.
Like, it just is.
Like, it's actually just good.
Like, it's...
Um...
Dude, it was...
It was good.
Also, bro, I...
I'm gonna say it.
I fucking love that lobby.
Chat.
I loved that lobby.
Like, that was a really...
That was a really, really fun couple of games.
I fucked with that hard, bro.
That was really good.
Dude, it was.
It was just...
It was just good vibes.
It was good vibes.
I think we're gonna try and do Dale and Dawson on Monday.
I think I'm gonna also try and do Mario Party.
I'm gonna invite Doki to the Dale and Dawson lobby.
And I think I'll try and run back the exact same squad for Mario Party.
So it's after Dale and Dawson.
Dude, I wanna...
I definitely... I wanna... I wanna invite Doki to more things, 100%.
Dude, she's great.
I love her.
Like, it's the same thing I said before the chat with, like, Hyun.
Like, just... I just love...
Like, people with, like, good energy, I still don't like to invite them and stuff, you know?
Dude, that was really fun.
Dude, that was insane.
Yeah, no, 100%.
We invite... We invite Doki.
Dude, I love Doki.
That was really... Dude, she's got, like, a...
She's got great fucking energy.
Great fucking energy, dude.
Like, high-key fuck with her energy.
Like, high-key, high-key, high-key fuck with her energy.
Bruh, that was...
Great.